WELL, GOOD AFTERNOON, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US FOR THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE. WE HAVE QUITE A QUITE
AN AGENDA IN FRONT OF US. AND
WE'RE GOING TO SAY THANK YOU
AHEAD OF TIME FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AS WE WORK OUR WAY THROUGH OUR
LENGTHY AGENDA BEFORE WE GET
INTO ANYTHING ELSE, WE'D LIKE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. MADAM
SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL? MAGUIRE. HERE. MAGUIRE
HERE. GROVE. HERE. GROVE. HERE.
EGGMAN. JONES. I'M HERE. JONES.
HERE. LAIRD. HERE. LAIRD HERE.
QUORUM. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
COMMITTEE. A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED, AS WE TYPICALLY DO.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP SOME
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS, SOME
ADMINISTRATIVE ITEMS. FIRST, WE
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO EACH OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HERE
TO APPEAR IN FRONT OF THE
COMMITTEE. THIS IS GOING TO TAKE
US A FEW MINUTES TO GET THROUGH
OUR HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS, AND THEN
WE'LL GET RIGHT INTO THE MEAT OF
TODAY'S BUSINESS. SO FIRST AND
FOREMOST, WE'RE GOING TO JUMP TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO ON OUR AGENDA.
THIS IS GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES
NOT REQUIRED TO APPEAR. WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO TAKE TWO
SEPARATE VOTES UNDER NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR. FIRST AND
FOREMOST, LET'S TAKE UP OUR
FIRST VOTE. THAT WOULD BE ON
ITEMS E, F, G AND I UNDER
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR. IS THERE A
MOTION FOR ITEMS TWO, E, F, G
AND I SO MOVED. WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MADAM VICE CHAIR. MADAM
SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL? MCGUIRE. AYE. MCGUIRE.
AYE. GROVE. AYE GROVE. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. JONES.
JONES AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE. 5
TO 0. THAT'S A50 VOTE. THAT
MOTION PASSES. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
COMMITTEE. WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
TAKING UP OUR SECOND ITEM UNDER
NUMBER TWO. GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR. WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
SEE IF THERE'S A MOTION ON ITEM
TWO H. ITEM TWO H. IS THERE A
MOTION MOVE? SENATOR LAIRD MAKES
THE MOTION. MADAM SECRETARY, CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL?
MCGUIRE. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
GROVE. NOT VOTING. GROVE. NOT
VOTING. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE.
JONES JONES. NOT VOTING. LAIRD.
LAIRD. AYE 3 TO 0. THAT IS A30
VOTE. THAT MOTION IS APPROVED.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE MOVING ON
TO ITEM NUMBER THREE. REFERENCE
OF BILLS TO COMMITTEE. I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. SO MOVED. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MADAM VICE
CHAIR. MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL? MCGUIRE.
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. GROVE. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE.
JONES. JONES. AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD.
AYE 5 TO 0. IT'S A50 VOTE. THAT
MOTION IS APPROVED. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
MOVING ON TO COMMITTEE
APPOINTMENTS. COMMITTEE
APPOINTMENTS? IS THERE A MOTION
TO APPROVE? SO MOVED. WE HAVE
MADAM VICE CHAIR WITH A MOTION
UNDER SECTION FOUR, FIVE AND
SIX. YES, FOR FIVE, FOUR, FIVE
AND SIX. MADAM SECRETARY, CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL?
MCGUIRE. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
GROVE AYE. GROVE. AYE. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. AYE. JONES AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD. HI. LAIRD. AYE. 5 TO
0. THAT IS A50 VOTE. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP SUBCOMMITTEE.
SUBCOMMITTEE RATIFICATION. IS
THERE A MOTION TO APPROVE? OH,
WE JUST. OH YES, WE DID OKAY.
THAT WE ARE EFFICIENT. ALL
RIGHT. NOW WE'RE GOING TO BE
GOING TO FLOOR ACKNOWLEDGMENTS.
FLOOR ACKNOWLEDGMENTS. WE HAVE A
REQUEST TO BE ABLE TO TAKE UP
TWO SEPARATE VOTES. WE'D LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO SEE IF THERE IS A
MOTION ON OUR FIRST VOTE FOR
ITEMS SEVEN, EIGHT, NINE, TEN,
11, 13 AND 14. SO MOVED. WE HAVE
A MOTION BY MADAM VICE CHAIR.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL? MCGUIRE AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. GROVE I. GROVE.
AYE. EGGMAN EGGMAN. AYE. JONES.
JONES. AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE. 5
TO 0. THAT'S A FIVE. CHAIR I
WOULD MOVE NUMBER 12. THANK.
MOVING. NUMBER 12. YES LOOK AT
THAT. WE HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. I THINK MR. LAIRD WAS
IN FIRST. ALL RIGHT, SO THERE WE
GO I GET PRIORITY. THERE WE GO.
SO WE HAVE ON OUR VOTE NUMBER
ONE. THAT WAS APPROVED ON A50
VOTE. WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
GOING TO VOTE NUMBER TWO ON THE
FLOOR. ACKNOWLEDGMENTS. THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER 12. WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MR. LAIRD. MADAM SECRETARY,
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL NÓ
MCGUIRE. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE
GROVE. AYE. GROVE. AYE. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. AYE. JONES JONES. NOT
VOTING. LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE. 4 TO
0. THAT IS A40 VOTE. THAT MOTION
PASSES. ALL RIGHT, LOOK AT THAT.
WE'RE DONE WITH OUR
HOUSEKEEPING. VERY GRATEFUL. WE
ARE GOING TO WELCOME TO
COMMITTEE REGENT LEE AND REGENT
TERRACE. IF YOU COULD PLEASE
COME FORWARD. WE'LL LET THEM
COME FORWARD AS THEY DO. WE WANT
TO FIRST TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO REGENT
SARRIS AND REGENT LEE FOR THEIR
COMMITMENT NOT JUST TO THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA, BUT TO THE
STUDENTS OF THE UC SYSTEM.
REGENT LEE, REGENT SARRIS,
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE 1 OR 2
MINUTES FOR OPENING TESTIMONY.
WE'LL THEN OPEN IT UP FOR THE
COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS AND
CONVERSATION AND ANY QUESTIONS
THAT THEY MAY HAVE, IN YOUR
OPENING, WE WELCOME YOU TO
ADVANCE ANY ACKNOWLEDGMENTS OF
GUESTS WHO MAY BE HERE IN THE
AUDIENCE OR WATCHING AT HOME OR
AT THE OFFICE. I'LL BE KEEPING
TIME AS YOU GET CLOSE TO THAT
TWO MINUTES. I'LL GIVE YOU A
32ND PROMPT. REGENT LEE, WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH YOU AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO REGENT
SARRIS. REGENT LEE, WELCOME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. I'D LIKE TO
START BY THANKING THE MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERING MY
APPOINTMENT. I ALSO WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR STAFF'S TIME.
WE HAD SOME GOOD CONVERSATIONS
THAT I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TODAY. IT IS AN HONOR
TO BE CONSIDERED FOR THE UC
BOARD OF REGENTS, AND I'M
GRATEFUL TO THE GOVERNOR AND
THIS COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO INTRODUCE MY
HUSBAND, RYAN GRAHAM, AND MY
PARENTS, WAN HOON LEE AND JUNG
HWAN LEE, WHO ARE HERE WITH ME
TODAY. THEY HAVE SUPPORTED ME
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS AND I
WOULD NOT BE WHO I AM WITHOUT
THESE IMPORTANT PEOPLE IN MY
LIFE. OVER 50 YEARS AGO, MY
PARENTS UPROOTED THEIR LIVES
FROM SOUTH KOREA TO MOVE TO
AMERICA. MORE SPECIFICALLY, THEY
EMIGRATED TO GUAM. THEY CAME
BECAUSE THIS COUNTRY WAS FULL OF
POSSIBILITY. AND FROM GUAM, WE
MOVED QUITE A BIT TO SEOUL,
KOREA, BEFORE SETTLING IN A
SMALL SUBURBAN COMMUNITY IN
MICHIGAN. MY PARENTS RAN A GAS
STATION 15 HOURS A DAY, SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK, TO PROVIDE FOR MY
TWO SISTERS AND ME AND THEIR
HARD WORK ENABLED ALL OF US TO
ATTEND COLLEGE. MY UNDERGRADUATE
AND GRADUATE EDUCATION WAS
FURTHER FUNDED WITH PELL GRANTS,
LOANS, AND WORK STUDY. FINANCIAL
AID. THROUGH PERSEVERANCE,
SUPPORTIVE MENTORS, AND GOOD
LUCK, I HAVE BEEN FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO BUILD A CAREER IN LAW,
FINANCE, STRATEGY, AND MEDIA AND
ENTERTAINMENT. AS A MEMBER OF
THE UC BOARD OF REGENTS, I HAVE
BEEN PROVIDED THE INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTRIBUTE IN
SUPPORT OF Kò SHARED VALUES AND
GOALS TOWARDS ADDRESSING
IMPORTANT ISSUES FACING OUR
CAMPUSES AND ITS STUDENTS. AT
THE END OF THE DAY, WE RECOGNIZE
THAT OUR EFFORTS AT AIMED NOT
ONLY AT ENSURING A POSITIVE
EXPERIENCE FOR OUR STUDENTS
WHILE AT èC, BUT EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT, WE ARE BUILDING OUR
FUTURE WORKFORCE FOR CAL, FOR
CALIFORNIA. I'M HONORED TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU AS YOU
CONSIDER MY APPOINTMENT, AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE. WE'RE
NOW GOING TO TRANSITION TO
REGENT SARRIS. REGENT SARRIS,
WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU, SIR. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. YOU'RE GOOD TO
GO. IF YOU DON'T MIND BRINGING
THE MIC A LITTLE CLOSER AND THEN
YOU'LL BE GOOD. THERE YOU GO.
OKAY, IT HAS BEEN A GREAT HONOR
FOR ME TO HAVE BEEN NOMINATED TO
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF REGENTS BY GOVERNOR
NEWSOM. I'VE BEEN A WRITER, A
PROFESSOR OF AMERICAN LITERATURE
AND WRITING, A TRIBAL LEADER AND
BUSINESSMAN, AND A
PHILANTHROPIST. I HAVE TAUGHT AT
THE UNIVERSITY LEVEL FOR 35
YEARS, TEN OF WHICH WAS AT UCLA
AS A PROFESSOR IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF ENGLISH. BEFORE I WAS A
PROFESSOR, I WAS A STUDENT, AN
UNDERGRADUATE AT UCLA, AS A
TROUBLED YOUTH, AS SOMEONE WHO
DID NOT READ A BOOK UNTIL THE
11TH GRADE, I KNOW WHAT
EDUCATION CAN DO. AND THAT WAS
AND IS AND MUST CONTINUE TO BE
WHAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA DOES BETTER THAN ANY
PUBLIC INSTITUTION ANYWHERE. AS
A UC REGENT, NOT ONLY CAN I KEEP
MY FEET IN EDUCATION, BUT HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PLAY A ROLE
IN THE GUARANTEE OF THE
UNIVERSITY EXCELLENCE AND
EXCELLENCE THAT WILL SHAPE AND
INFORM AND SUSTAINABLE FUTURE
FOR ALL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE
HERE. WHAT WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO DO NOW IS OPEN IT UP TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS. WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH SENATOR LAIRD. SENATOR
LAIRD GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND THANK YOU BOTH
FOR THE TIME TO TALK. I REALLY
APPRECIATED IT. IT WAS GREAT TO
GET TO KNOW BOTH OF YOU, AND I'M
REALLY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
SERVICE. I DID POINT OUT THAT
YOU JUST GET A FEW EXPENSES
REIMBURSED. OTHERWISE THIS IS A
DONATION. SO, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO DO THAT. I
THOUGHT I'D START WITH I HAVE A
COUPLE OF TOPICS. AND THEN
ANOTHER QUESTION AND THE TOPIC
OF THE DAY SEEMS TO BE THE
BALANCE BETWEEN SAFETY AND FREE
SPEECH ON THE CAMPUSES AND èC
HAS BEEN IN THE MIDDLE, WITH
SOME CAMPUSES HAVING JUST VERY
DIFFERENT SITUATIONS THAN OTHERS
. HOW DO YOU SEE YOUR ROLE AS A
REGENT? IN THAT BALANCE BETWEEN
SAFETY AND FREE SPEECH? AND
MAYBE WE'LL START WITH REGENT
LEE AND GO TO REGENT.
ABSOLUTELY. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION, SENATOR, IT IS MY
BELIEF THAT THERE IS NO HIGHER
PURPOSE FOR AN ACADEMIC
INSTITUTION THAN TO FOSTER A
CULTURE WHERE FREE SPEECH IS
VALUED AND IS ALLOWED TO THRIVE,
WHETHER THAT'S THROUGH DEBATE OR
AN EXCHANGE OF IDEAS OR EVEN
PEACEFUL DEMONSTRATIONS. AND,
YOU KNOW, THE POINT OF A PROTEST
IS TO BRING ATTENTION TO YOUR
CAUSE AND TO BUILD SOLIDARITY
AND ALLYSHIP AND TO CHANGE
MINDS, OUR MOTTO IS FIAT LUX,
LET THERE BE LIGHT. AND SO
ENCOURAGING STUDENTS TO DEBATE
AND THINK ABOUT COMPLICATED AND
THORNY ISSUES IS WHAT HIGHER
EDUCATION IS ALL ABOUT IN MY
MIND. THAT SAID, THERE IS A
LIMIT TO FREE SPEECH AND IT IS
NOT AN ABSOLUTE RIGHT. AND WHEN
IT CROSSES THE LINE INTO
VIOLENCE OR VANDALISM OF OUR
PROPERTY OR HARASSMENT OF
STUDENTS, BECAUSE OF THAT, THEIR
IDENTITY, THAT'S THAT'S WHEN
IT'S NOT OKAY. AND THE RIGHTS OF
OTHERS NEED TO BE PROTECTED AS
WELL. AND SO THE BALANCING OF
BOTH OF THOSE TENSIONS IS WHAT I
BELIEVE OUR ROLE AS REGENTS NEED
TO BE, AND, YOU KNOW, WE HAVEN'T
GOTTEN IT RIGHT EVERY SINGLE
TIME YOU'VE YOU'VE REFERENCED
THAT. AND WE HAD A GOOD
DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT, BUT I
THINK IT WAS GOOD FOR US TO ASK
TOUGH QUESTIONS OF OUR
ADMINISTRATORS AND TO DEMAND
SOME CHANGES. AND SO I WAS GLAD
TO SEE CHANCELLOR BLOCK, FOR
INSTANCE, AT UCLA, WITH A SENSE
OF URGENCY, MAKE SOME CHANGES AT
THAT CAMPUS IN PARTICULAR. THANK
YOU. YES. AS I THANK YOU,
SENATOR LAIRD, THE AS I'VE SAID
EARLIER, THIS THESE PROTESTS
HAVE CREATED A SITUATION WHERE
THERE'S A UNIQUE CHALLENGE. THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HAS HAD
MANY PROTESTS, A HISTORY OF
PROTESTS. THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
WE'VE HAD STUDENT AGAINST
STUDENT. IT USED TO BE IN THE
60S. OF COURSE, WE HAD. WE WERE
AGAINST VIETNAM AND WE MAYBE
WERE AFRAID OF THE POLICE COMING
IN OR WHATEVER TO GET US. BUT
NEVER WERE WE AFRAID OF EACH
OTHER. AND I THINK THAT
CHALLENGE IN PARTICULAR HAS
RAISED ALL THESE QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHAT IS THE FIRST AMENDMENT AND
HOW IS IT GOING TO BE APPLIED.
VERY CLEARLY STATED, THE FIRST
AMENDMENT DOES NOT PROTECT
VIOLENCE AGAINST OTHER PEOPLE,
DOES NOT PROTECT VANDALISM TO
PROPERTY, DOES NOT PROTECT
BLOCKING STUDENTS FROM GOING OR
AND PROFESSORS GOING TO CLASS.
ANY OF THOSE THINGS. IT ALLOWS
YOU TO SAY AND ORGANIZE WITH
OTHERS WHAT YOU THINK, NOT TO
INCITE HARM OR VIOLENCE TO
SOMEBODY ELSE. AND THAT'S WHERE
WE CAN, IN ACCORDANCE WITH
UNIVERSITY POLICIES ON THE CODES
OF CONDUCT, CAN ENFORCE THESE
LAWS, AND THEY SHOULD BE
ENFORCED AND LET ME I'M SORRY.
AND IT'S MY JOB, OR I SEE IT AS
OUR JOB AS REGENTS TO INFLUENCE
AND WORK WITH OTHER REGIONS TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR
ADMINISTRATORS, AS REGENT LEE
HAS SAID, ADHERE TO THESE
POLICIES AND MAKE SURE THEY'RE
ENACTED. AND, WELL, JUST A QUICK
FOLLOW UP, BECAUSE WE'VE JUST
BEEN FOCUSING ON WHAT'S HAPPENED
LATELY. BUT THERE WAS VANDALISM,
TO THE HOUSE OF THE PRESIDENT
THAT WAS RACIST IN NATURE. AND
IN COMING BEFORE THE REGENTS,
HOW DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU DO ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT
OVER TIME, WELL, I FIRST, FIRST
OF ALL, I WANT TO I FEEL VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT HIM WHEN I'VE
BEEN DOING WORK FOR MY TRIBE,
I'VE HAD WHEN TEACHING, I HAD
NOTICES ON MY DOOR. THAT'S ONLY
GOOD. INDIAN IS A DEAD INDIAN
AND ALL THAT KIND OF THING. AND
IT'S A FRIGHTENING THING. AND
AGAIN, WHAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO DO, IT'S OUR JOB TO MAKE SURE
THAT HE AND HIS WIFE ARE SAFE,
WHATEVER THAT'S GOING TO TAKE.
SO WORKING WITH HIM, HE HAS TO
BE SAFE. BUT CERTAINLY IF YOU'RE
ASKING, IS THERE ANY ROOM FOR
ANY KIND OF RACIST COMMENTS ON
HIS HOME OR OR ELSEWHERE?
ABSOLUTELY NOT. THAT'S BREAKING
THE LAW. YEAH, THERE WERE
DEFINITELY INCIDENCES OF NOT
ONLY THE HATE SPEECH THAT WAS
SCRAWLED ON HIS HOME, BUT BUT
TRESPASSING. AND SO, YOU KNOW,
LIKE REGENT SARAH SAID,
ENFORCING THOSE LAWS AND MAKING
SURE THAT THEY FEEL SAFE IN
THEIR OWN HOME AND GIVING THEM
OPTIONS IF THEY DON'T FEEL SAFE.
I THINK THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF
DEBATES THAT WE HAD AS A BOARD.
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. THEN
THE OTHER MAJOR POLICY QUESTION
I WANTED TO ASK ABOUT IF WE
TALKED ABOUT IN OUR MEETING,
WHICH IS THE WHOLE ISSUE OF
GROWTH AND HOW YOU ALLOCATE
STUDENTS TO CAMPUSES, HOW YOU
MAKE SURE THERE'S HOUSING FOR
STUDENTS, HOW YOU DEAL WITH THE
IMPACTS OF TRAFFIC. AND, JUST
WHAT PERSPECTIVES DO YOU BRING
TO THAT AS REGENTS? AND MAYBE
WE'LL START WITH REGENT LEE THIS
TIME. YEAH. YOU SEE SUCH A
UNIQUE ECONOMIC ENGINE FOR EACH
OF YOUR COMMUNITIES, AND BEING A
GOOD STEWARD OF THAT COMMUNITY
AND BEING A GOOD PARTNER FOR ALL
OF YOU AS YOU WERE WHEN YOU WERE
ON THE CITY COUNCIL, FOR
INSTANCE, THOSE ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT TOPICS FOR ME TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE BUILDING
TRUST AND RESPECT FOR EACH
OTHER. TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
ON HOUSING, I KNOW WE'VE HAD,
YOU KNOW, 37,000 BEDS THAT HAVE
COME ONLINE SINCE 2011 AND
ADDITIONAL 15,000 THAT WILL
COME, COME ONLINE THROUGH 2028.
AND SO PRIORITIZING THESE BASIC
NEEDS FOR OUR STUDENTS HAS BEEN
CERTAINLY TOP OF MIND FOR US.
BUT EVEN AS WE THINK ABOUT GOING
FORWARD, WHAT CAN WE DO TO DO
MORE WITH WHAT WE HAVE AND THOSE
ARE SOME OF THE THINGS THAT I
WANTED TO HAVE ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH FOLKS LIKE
YOU. IS THERE A WAY FOR US TO,
HAVE MORE ONLINE COURSES, FOR
INSTANCE, OR BE MORE FLEXIBLE IN
SCHEDULING OR EVEN ENCOURAGING
STUDENTS TO COMPLETE THEIR
DEGREES IN THREE YEARS INSTEAD
OF FOUR? SO THEY HAVE THAT
COMPLETE EDUCATION, BUT THEY'RE
ABLE TO MOVE ON AND START THEIR
CAREERS SO THAT WE HAVE ROOM FOR
OTHERS. I APPRECIATE THAT, YEAH.
THE, THE CONUNDRUM IS THAT
THERE'S A GOAL OF HAVING 160,000
MORE STUDENTS IN THE NEXT, WHAT,
20 YEARS OR SO. SO THAT'S GOING
TO OBVIOUSLY BEG THE QUESTION,
WHERE DO THEY GO? AND THAT'S
GOING TO REQUIRE HOUSING. THAT
SAID, I WOULD CONCUR WITH WHAT
REGENT LEE SAID, THAT IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE WORK WITH
COMMUNITIES WHERE THE
UNIVERSITIES ARE LOCATED TO
REACH THE BEST GOAL OF WHERE AND
HOW HOUSING CAN WORK IN A WAY
THAT WORKS BEST WITH THE
COMMUNITY. INSTEAD OF AT ODDS
WITH THE COMMUNITY THAT'S THERE.
AS IN OUR DISCUSSION, YOU GAVE A
PERFECT EXAMPLE WITH SANTA CRUZ,
WHERE IT'S A COMMUNITY OF 60,000
PEOPLE, AND ALL OF A SUDDEN
YOU'VE GOT 20,000 MORE STUDENTS
THERE. THAT'S GOING TO CHANGE
THE DYNAMIC INSTANTLY. HOW DO
YOU DO THAT PEACEFULLY AND
COOPERATIVELY? THAT'S THE
QUESTION. THANK YOU. AND IT'S
COMPOUNDED BY THE FACT THAT SOME
OF THE STUDENTS NEVER LEAVE. SO,
ADDS TO THE HOUSING. THEN REGENT
SARRIS, LET ME JUST ASK YOU A
SINGULAR QUESTION. AND THAT IS
YOU INITIALLY FILED A FORM 700
THAT SHOWED NO REPORTABLE
INTEREST, AND THEN YOU AMENDED
IT TO SHOW THERE'S THESE
AMORPHOUS CATEGORIES, BUT AT
LEAST $200,000 OF INCOME, HOW
DID THAT COME ABOUT? AND THAT'S
I THINK THAT I REMEMBER, I WELL,
I MY THE FORMS ARE ALL SENT TO
OUR LEGAL THAT WORKED WITH YOUR
LEGAL AND I THINK INITIALLY WHAT
HAPPENED WAS THEY THOUGHT WELL
THEY WANT TO KNOW WHAT YOUR PER
CAPITA IS. AND ALL OF THESE
SORTS OF THINGS THAT GOT INTO
THE TRIBAL STUFF. AND THEY SAID
THEY I WAS INITIALLY TOLD, GREG,
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT. YOU'RE
FROM A SOVEREIGN NATION. YOU
DON'T HAVE TO REPORT
TRANSACTIONS OR FINANCES THAT
YOU HAVE WITHIN THAT. NATION,
WITHIN THAT, YOU KNOW, SOVEREIGN
NATION. AND THEN, OF COURSE, IT
BECAME VERY CLEAR ONCE OUR
LEGAL, OUR FOLKS TALKED TO ONE
ANOTHER THAT WAIT A MINUTE, YOU
DO HAVE TO REPORT REPORTABLE
INCOME. SO THEN WE WENT AHEAD
AND DID THAT AND SO NOW YOUR
AMENDMENT IS COMPLETE AND IT'S
ACCURATE. IT'S COMPLETE AND IT'S
ACCURATE OKAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I APPRECIATE THE RESPONSE
TO YOUR QUESTIONS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU.
THANK YOU. SENATOR EGGMAN, MADAM
VICE CHAIR AND THEN SENATOR
JONES. SENATOR EGGMAN, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND I'M SORRY WE
DIDN'T GET A CHANCE TO MEET, MY
QUESTION TO FOLLOW UP ON SENATOR
LAIRD'S FIRST ONE AROUND THE
TENOR ON CAMPUSES RIGHT NOW, AND
AS A FORMER FACULTY MEMBER AT A
AT CSU, BEING ABLE TO FACILITATE
CONVERSATIONS WHERE HEALTHY
DEBATES OCCUR, I THINK IS ONE OF
THE KEY THINGS THAT ONE WOULD
HOPE TO GAIN OUT OF AN
EDUCATION. SO IN IN LIGHT OF IT
SEEMING LIKE WE'RE LOSING THE
ABILITY TO HAVE CIVIL
CONVERSATIONS AND AS THE
UNIVERSITIES, ESPECIALLY THE UC,
IS A PREMIER LABORATORY, IF YOU
WILL, HOW DO YOU SEE HOW DO YOU
SEE THE UNIVERSITY BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
AROUND CIVILITY AND A DEBATE OF
IDEAS? YEAH, I'M SO GLAD YOU
ASKED THAT QUESTION, BECAUSE I
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT A LOT ABOUT THAT FOR THE
LAST YEAR. I MUST SAY THAT
HAVING BEEN TEACHING IN THE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM FOR SO LONG
AND THE REASON I WENT INTO IT IS
FOR THE VERY PURPOSE OF CREATING
LEARNING TO CREATE CONSENSUS,
THE IMPORTANCE AND PRIORITY OF
DIALOG, WHAT SEEMS TO HAVE
HAPPENED, ALONG WITH THE LARGER
THINGS SOCIAL SITUATIONS THAT
ARE HAPPENING, IS A POLARIZATION
WHERE IT SEEMS THAT SOME
FACULTY, AS WELL AS STUDENTS,
ARE MORE ABOUT TAKING SIDES
RATHER THAN DIALOG, WHICH WAS
THE MISSION OF THE UNIVERSITY.
AND SO I THINK A LOT OF
ATTENTION AND WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN, I'M AFRAID IT'LL
BACKFIRE, BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE
UNSAFE CAMPUSES AND ALL THAT
SORT OF THING, THE STUDENTS ARE
GOING TO BE UNCOMFORTABLE.
PARENTS ARE GOING TO BE
UNCOMFORTABLE. AND SO HOW ARE
THE STUDENTS PROTECTED? AND HOW
DO WE GET BACK TO WHAT OUR
MISSION WAS? SENATOR, THAT'S THE
QUESTION. AND I THINK A LOT OF
DISCUSSION, PERHAPS FINANCES
SOME OF THE PRESIDENT HAS MOVED
SOMEWHAT IN THIS DIRECTION, HAS
TO GO TO STRATEGIES OF CONSENSUS
AND CONSENSUS BUILDING AMONG
FACULTY AND STUDENTS ON ALL
ISSUES, BUT PARTICULARLY THE
CURRENT ONE. AS I SAID EARLIER,
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME WE'VE
SEEN STUDENT AGAINST STUDENT.
IT'S COME TO THIS AND WE SAW A
LITTLE BIT OF THIS COMING WITH
THE ISSUES OF THE PROUD BOYS AND
STUFF, HAVING SPEECHES ON THE
CAMPUSES AND OTHER STUDENTS
PROTESTING AND ALL OF THAT. AND
AGAIN, PEOPLE HAVE THE RIGHT TO
SAY THEIR OPINION, BUT THEY
DON'T HAVE A RIGHT TO GO TO THE
EXTENT WHERE THEY'RE BREAKING
THE LAW. AND WE MUST GET BACK TO
WHAT THE MISSION OF THIS
UNIVERSITY IS, THERE'S COUNTLESS
PEDAGOGIES THAT CAN HELP US WORK
ON THIS IN THE CLASSROOM. I'VE
USED THEM FOR YEARS, BUT IT
SEEMS THAT, WE'VE WE'RE
REFLECTING, UNFORTUNATELY, TOO
MUCH OF THE POLARIZATION ON
CAMPUS THAT IS GOING ON OUTSIDE
OF THE CAMPUS. JUST JUST TO
FOLLOW UP REAL QUICK ON ON WHAT
GREG JUST SAID, THE PRESIDENT
HAS ALLOCATED FUNDS TO COMBAT
AND EXPAND PROGRAMS TO COMBAT
ISLAMOPHOBE AND ANTI-SEMITISM
AND OTHER FORMS OF BIGOTRY AND
HATE. AND SO, YOU KNOW, CAN WE
USE THIS MOMENT TO HAVE AN
EDUCATIONAL, WRAPPER AROUND SOME
OF THE TOPICS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT? SO THAT WE CAN, YOU KNOW,
CHANGE MINDS IN A POSITIVE WAY,
AND SO, YOU KNOW, WORKING WITH,
YOU KNOW, ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
HILLEL TO GIVE LEADERS RESOURCES
SO THAT THEY CAN EQUIP THEIR OWN
CAMPUSES TO HAVE A MORE
INCLUSIVE ATMOSPHERE. I THINK
THOSE ARE ALL THE STEPS THAT
WE'VE TAKEN SO FAR. AND SO YOU
KNOW, AGAIN, CONTINUING TO FOCUS
ON THIS AND NOT REALLY HAVING
ALL THE ANSWERS MYSELF, BUT
TAKING THIS MOMENT TO ENSURE
THAT OUR STUDENTS ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THIS IS A TIME IN THEIR
LIVES WHERE THEY CAN AND SHOULD
BE, YOU KNOW, LEARNING MORE AND
BEING ABLE TO DEBATE IN A
CONSTRUCTIVE MANNER. AND IF YOU
WANT TO EVEN LOOK AT THE CURRENT
CLIMATE SENATOR AS AN
OPPORTUNITY MORE THAN EVER, IS
THERE AN OPPORTUNITY NOW TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS SITUATION, TO
SAY, HOW DO WE SOLVE PROBLEMS?
HOW DO WE DO THIS? WHAT DO WE DO
IN THE CLASSROOM? YEAH, YEAH.
NO, IT'S A GREAT OPPORTUNITY.
YEAH. IF WE USE IT. YES, YES,
AND THEN MY, MY SECOND QUESTION
IS JUST AROUND, I, I DON'T HAVE
A èC IN MY AREA, OR CSU OR
ANYTHING, BUT WE ARE CLOSE, TO
UC MERCED. AND SO I'VE BEEN OUT
I WAS OUT THERE A COUPLE OF
WEEKS AGO, AND THE QUEST, TO GET
A MEDICAL SCHOOL OPENED UP OUT
THERE. CAN YOU TELL ME YOUR
YOUR, YOUR, YOUR PLANS AND YOUR
IDEAS ABOUT HOW DO WE MAKE THAT
HAPPEN? AND ESPECIALLY IF WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT EQUITY AROUND THE
STATE? ABSOLUTELY. CENTRAL
VALLEY IS REALLY, YOU KNOW, A
PLACE THAT THAT NEEDS MORE
HEALTH CARE PRACTITIONERS. I
COULDN'T AGREE MORE, SENATOR. I
ACTUALLY HAD A ZOOM WITH A FEW,
FIRST YEAR PRIME STUDENTS AT UC
MERCED JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO, AND
EACH OF THEM WERE IN THEIR FIRST
YEAR OF THIS, YOU KNOW, BRAND
NEW PROGRAM. THEY'RE THE FIRST
COHORT AT MERCED. AND THEY ALL
HAD INCREDIBLE STORIES OF HOW
THEY CAME FROM THE VALLEY. THEY
WANT TO SERVE IN THE VALLEY AND
I'D REALLY WANTED TO MAKE THIS
PART OF THEIR LIVES. AND THE UC
EDUCATION IS, YOU KNOW, ALLOWS
THEM TO DO THAT. SO SO GIVING
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES MEANS THAT WE
NEED THOSE FACILITIES. AND SO
I'M GLAD TO SEE THAT WE HAVE THE
PROGRAMS IN PLACE TO HAVE ALMOST
LIKE AS A FIRST STEP, BUT YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT MORE NEEDS
TO BE DONE TO HAVE MORE
EQUITABLE OPPORTUNITIES, NOT
ONLY FOR THE PATIENTS IN THE
AREA, BUT BUT THE DOCTORS WHO
WILL BE SERVING THERE. THANK
YOU, ABSOLUTELY. IT'S AN AREA
THAT NEEDS HEALTH CARE. AND WHY
NOT HAVE THE UNIVERSITY OF
MEDICAL CENTER THERE BE THE
NEXUS OF THAT? IT MAKES PERFECT
SENSE. WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS.
I'VE HAD SOME DISCUSSIONS ON THE
SIDE ABOUT WE'LL HAVE DAVIS, YOU
KNOW, DAVIS WELL, DAVIS HAS ITS
AREA, MERCED IS SEPARATE AND
MERCED HAS A LARGE COMMUNITY.
THE VALLEY THERE THAT NEEDS THIS
. AND THEY DON'T HAVE THE
MEDICAL FACILITIES. AND SENATOR
MCGUIRE, I HAVE TO SAY SHOUT OUT
TO CHANCELLOR MUNOZ. HE'S BEEN
WONDERFUL IN RECRUITING, THE
LATINO STUDENTS, SUPPORTING THEM
. HE CAME TO SANTA ROSA, TO
ROSELAND UNIVERSITY PREP AND
TALKED TO STUDENTS AND HAS
OFFERED A BUS TO TAKE THEM DOWN
THERE TO SEE MERCED. A LOT OF
ENERGY, A LOT OF ENERGY. AND
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO SEE. AND
WE AND WE NEED TO SEE AGAIN THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THESE YOUNG
LATINOS, LATINAS, WE NEED TO SEE
THE OPPORTUNITY THAT THEY HAVE
THE OPTION TO GO INTO TO
MEDICINE AND SERVE THEIR
COMMUNITIES. IT MAKES PERFECT
SENSE. NOW, YOU SAID, OF COURSE,
THE QUESTION, HOW DO YOU DO IT?
WELL, THEN WE HAVE TO COME UP
WITH THE MONEY. SO THANK YOU.
YEAH SEE, THERE WE GO. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, MADAM VICE CHAIR. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. I APPRECIATE THAT. THANK
YOU BOTH FOR MEETING WITH ME
THIS AFTERNOON OR THIS MORNING
BEFORE THE MEETING THIS
AFTERNOON. I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE IT, I THINK YOU LIKE
MY COLLEAGUE SAID THAT IT'S KIND
OF. YOU'RE DONATING YOUR TIME,
BUT I LOVE AND APPRECIATE ALL
YOUR PASSION THAT YOU HAVE, YOUR
STORY IS, ACTUALLY, YOU WENT
ELEVATED HIGHER THAN ME, BUT IN
THE BEGINNING OF OUR LIFE, BEING
JUVENILE DELINQUENTS. AND THOSE
THINGS AREN'T. WE HAVE THAT SAME
THING. BUT NOW YOU'RE A REGENT
IN THE UCS. THE UC SYSTEM, AND
WILL BE A REGENT AGAIN. I'M
FAIRLY CONFIDENT. I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS THAT I'M
GOING TO ASK, SIMILAR TO WHAT WE
DISCUSSED IN MY OFFICE. AND, SO
I'LL JUST AND WHOEVER WOULD LIKE
TO ANSWER THEM, THAT'S
COMPLETELY FINE. UNLESS, MR.
CHAIR, YOU WANT ME TO IDENTIFY
EACH PERSON OR HOW DO YOU WANT?
PLEASE, MADAM VICE CHAIR,
CONTINUE. SO, WE TALKED ABOUT
POLICIES FOR THIS, STATEWIDE ON
THE, THE UC SYSTEM. WE TALKED
ABOUT POLICIES. AND IS THERE A
POLICY ON TEMPORARY HOUSING AND
TENT TINTING? YES, THERE IS ALL
THE ALL THE CAMPUSES HAVE A
VERSION OF THAT POLICY THAT
PROHIBITS SOME CAMPUSES, I
BELIEVE, CALL IT, TEMPORARY
HOUSING, SOME CALL IT
ENCAMPMENTS. BUT EACH OF THE
CAMPUSES DOES HAVE A POLICY
PROHIBITING THOSE THINGS.
SENATOR GROVE AND IS THERE A IF
YOU VIOLATE THE POLICY, IS THERE
A CONSEQUENCE FOR VIOLATING THAT
POLICY OR JUST FINDING OUT THAT
THERE SHOULD BE? YEAH. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, THAT THERE IS A
PROCESS. YES. THAT'S RIGHT. OKAY
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, REGENT
LEE, WE TALKED ALSO ABOUT
NUMBERS AND WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
THE NUMBERS IN THESE PROTESTS,
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE SEEM TO
BE SPENDING ALL OF OUR TIME ON.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE NUMBERS
IN THESE PROTESTS ARE OUTSIDE
AGITATORS, LIKE THE ONE THAT WAS
ARRESTED AT UCLA? YEAH. WELL,
THE ONE THAT WAS ARRESTED WAS AN
OUTSIDE, NOT NOT ASSOCIATED WITH
THE CAMPUS AT ALL. NOT A
STUDENT, NOT A FACULTY MEMBER.
SO HE WAS AN OUTSIDE AGITATOR,
AND AS YOU HEARD FROM CHANCELLOR
BLOCK'S TESTIMONY LAST, LAST
WEEK AT CONGRESS, YOU KNOW,
THERE ARE OVER 100
INVESTIGATIONS GOING ON NOW ON
CAMPUS JUST TO IDENTIFY WHO
THESE PERPETRATORS ARE. TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION, IT'S A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT AT EACH
CAMPUS. HOW WHAT PERCENTAGE IS,
ARE FROM THE CAMPUS AND WHO ARE
FROM OUTSIDE? I THINK WE'VE
HEARD EVERYTHING FROM 50 TO 70%
COULD BE STUDENTS. AND SO, YOU
KNOW, IT IS A MIX DEPENDING ON
WHERE YOU ARE. OKAY. AND WE ALSO
TALKED AND I UNDERSTAND YOUR
RESPONSE, BUT I JUST WANT THE
PUBLIC TO UNDERSTAND IT'S LIKE
THESE OUTSIDE AGITATORS THAT
HAVE NO BUSINESS BEING ON THE
CAMPUS. THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
SCHOOL, THEY'RE NOT EDUCATING AT
THE SCHOOL. THEY'RE NOT A PARENT
VISITING THE SCHOOL, THERE'S NO
BUSINESS, FOR UNIVERSITY
BUSINESS TO BE THERE, OR STUDENT
INTEREST OR STUDENT BUSINESS TO
BE THERE. HOW DO YOU KEEP THEM
OUT OF A PUBLIC UNIVERSITY,
WHICH IS ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE. I'M
ASSUMING IT'S YOU CAN'T KEEP
ANYONE OUT. BUT WHAT YOU CAN DO
IS HAVE PEOPLE ARRESTED FOR
BREAKING THE LAW. REMEMBER,
THERE'S NOT A FENCE AROUND A
PUBLIC UNIVERSITY. SO IN FACT,
MANY UNIVERSITIES, PEOPLE FROM
THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES WALK THEIR
DOGS OR JUST WALK THROUGH AND
DON'T HAVE ANY AFFILIATION.
SENATOR, WITH WITH THE
UNIVERSITY. BUT THAT IS A REALLY
GOOD QUESTION BECAUSE THERE'S NO
WAY OF I.D.ING OR CHECKING
EVERYBODY. YOU HAVE A CAMPUS
WITH 40,000 STUDENTS AND ANOTHER
15,000 FACULTY AND STAFF. YOU
KNOW, YOU HAVE A CITY THERE. AND
SO IT'S OPEN, SO THE ONLY THING
THAT CAN HAPPEN IS, IF THE
PERSON AGAIN, IS VANDALIZING, VÌ
OR HARASSING DOING ANY OF THOSE
THINGS, THEY'RE SUBJECT TO
ARREST. THEY'RE BREAKING LAWS.
AND THEN, JUST A COUPLE OF MORE
QUESTIONS REGARDING WHAT'S GOING
ON ON CAMPUS NOW. AND, AND BOTH
OF YOUR RESPONSES EARLIER FROM
MY COLLEAGUES ABOUT STUDENT
SAFETY AND, WE BUT WE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE RIGHTS OF
THOSE STUDENTS, AGAIN, NOT
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT, BUT THESE
PARENTS AND THESE STUDENTS HAVE
PAID A HIGH DOLLAR FOR THIS
EDUCATION AND SOME OF THE MOST
PRESTIGIOUS EDUCATIONAL,
PRESTIGIOUS UNIVERSITIES IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD. THEY THEY'VE PAID
FOR THEIR CHILD TO BE EDUCATED
THERE, AND THEY'VE BEEN DENIED
ACCESS TO THEIR CLASSROOMS TO BE
EDUCATED. AND WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS IN MY OFFICE, THAT THEY'VE
BEEN DENIED THE GRADUATION
ABILITY WHEN MOST OF THESE
STUDENTS WERE DENIED ABILITY TO
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL
BECAUSE OF COVID. SO WE TALKED
ABOUT MONUMENTAL MILESTONES IN
SOMEONE'S LIFE, AND THOSE TWO
THINGS GRADUATION FROM HIGH
SCHOOL AND A GRADUATION FROM
COLLEGE, AGAIN, GETTING YOUR
DRIVER'S LICENSE AND OTHER
THINGS, GETTING MARRIED. THOSE
THINGS ARE MONUMENTAL THINGS IN
YOUR LIFE. HOW DO YOU JUSTIFY OR
HOW DO THOSE CHANCELLORS JUSTIFY
SHUTTING DOWN AN EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITY FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS TO GRADUATE AT THE
BEHEST OF PROTESTERS, THAT
SOMETIMES ARE OUTSIDE AGITATORS?
WE HAVE AN AGREEMENT WITH
PARENTS AND STUDENTS TO EDUCATE
THOSE STUDENTS. THEY PAY FOR
SOMETHING. WE MUST GIVE IT TO
THEM, THEY EXPECT SOMETHING.
THERE'S NO JUSTIFICATION THAT I
OR ANY I THINK ANYBODY CAN SAY
THAT WOULD ALLOW, ANYONE TO LOCK
SOMEONE OUT OF A CLASSROOM OR
OUT OF A LECTURE OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT. THERE IS NO
JUSTIFICATION THÀNH SHORT OF A
FIRE BEING IN A BUILDING. SO I
DON'T KNOW HOW ELSE TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION, SENATOR, I
APPRECIATE THAT RESPONSE, I
REALLY DO, AND I APPRECIATE
THAT. YOU KNOW, YOU, REGENT LEE,
YOU MADE THE SIMILAR STATEMENT
IN THE OFFICE AND I JUST
APPRECIATE THAT YOU GUYS ARE
GOING TO HELP TAKE ON THIS
CHALLENGE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS SOME TYPE OF BALANCE WE
ALL SUPPORT. I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANYBODY IN THIS DÍAS
DOES NOT SUPPORT FREE SPEECH,
BUT IT CAN'T BE RACIST. IT CAN'T
BE ANTI-SEMITIC. ABSOLUTELY. I
WHEN I SAW THAT WHAT WAS GOING
ON IN THE UCLA CAMPUS, THERE WAS
ANOTHER THING ON INSTAGRAM OR
ONE OF THE SOCIAL MEDIAS, AND IT
WAS LIKE IN VIENNA WHEN THEY
WERE BLOCKING JEWISH STUDENTS
BACK THEN TO GO TO COLLEGE. AND
THAT WAS A VERY SCARY FEELING TO
LOOK AT THOSE TWO COMPARISONS OF
BOTH CAMPUSES SIDE BY SIDE.
YEAH. AND WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
IN YOUR OFFICE AS WELL, SENATOR.
PART OF THE ANSWER HERE IS
EDUCATION AND REMEMBERING OUR
HISTORY AND THINGS LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL
DAY THAT, YOU KNOW, YOU
SUPPORTED SO ROBUSTLY IS PART OF
THE ANSWER TO WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE, SO AS YOU REFERENCE,
YOU KNOW, COMPARISONS TO THE
PAST, REMINDING PEOPLE THAT WE
CAN'T FORGET THE MISTAKES THAT
WE'VE MADE IN THE PAST. THANK
YOU. AND I GUESS MY LAST
QUESTION IS, IS THAT. AND IT'S
VERY AND I'M GOING TO DO A
COUPLE OF THEM, BUT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT IT. COULD I JUST ADD TO
THAT? THANK YOU, SENATOR,
RECENTLY AT A REGENTS MEETING,
IT CAME UP WHERE THEY WERE
BLOCKING THE MAIN ENTRANCE TO
THE BERKELEY. RIGHT. AND THEY
WERE SAYING THAT JEWISH STUDENTS
COULDN'T GO PAST AND ALL THAT
SORT OF THING. AND THEN SOME
OTHER. I FORGET WHERE THE
COMMENT CAME. THEY SAID, WELL,
THEY CAN GO AROUND. WELL, NO,
WE'RE EQUAL. AND THAT'S LIKE THE
SAME THING IN THE SOUTH SAYING
USE THE BACK DOOR. YEAH. SO
AGAIN, THOSE KINDS OF THINGS ARE
JUST COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE. I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AGAIN,
SIR. ON THAT. I, YOU MENTIONED
THAT YOU RECENTLY HAD A MEETING
WITH THE CHANCELLORS. YOU TALKED
ABOUT A SPECIAL MEETING THAT YOU
HAD WITH THE CHANCELLORS, IN IN
MY OFFICE, I DON'T HAVE TO ASK
THE QUESTION. I'M JUST GOING TO
MAKE A STATEMENT BECAUSE I THINK
YOUR RESPONSES WERE VERY
ADEQUATE IN MY OFFICE. IF YOU
WANT TO RESPOND, YOU CAN. I JUST
AM VERY FRUSTRATED WITH THE
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT WE ARE
SPENDING ON THIS SITUATION
VERSUS MAKING SURE THAT WE
FOLLOW THE MISSION OF THE UC
SYSTEM THAT SAYS, NUMBER ONE, IT
TO ADVANCE AND EXTEND KNOWLEDGE
AND LEARNING AND CULTURE,
ESPECIALLY THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA, TO PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITY FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
DEVELOP INTELLECTUALLY,
PERSONALLY AND PROFESSIONALLY,
AND TO PREPARE SIGNIFICANT
NUMBERS OF EDUCATED, RESPONSIBLE
PEOPLE TO MAKE CONTRIBUTIONS TO
CONTRIBUTE TO CALIFORNIA'S
SCHOOLS ECONOMY, CULTURE AND
FUTURE. YOU KNOW, THAT'S WHAT
YOU SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON AND
YOU SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON
FILLING VACANCIES FOR, YOU KNOW,
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES THAT
WE DON'T HAVE. WE SHOULD BE
FOCUSING ON PREPARING FOR THOSE
ADDITIONAL 160,000 OR WHATEVER
NUMBER STUDENTS THAT ARE COMING
IN. WE SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE AN
EDUCATIONAL FACILITY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THAT WE LACK UP
IN THE STOCKTON OR NORTHERN PART
OF THE AREA. LOOKING AT UC
MERCED, THOSE ARE THE THINGS WE
SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON, NOT
ANTI-SEMITISM, NOT RACIST
REMARKS, NOT BLOCKING STUDENTS
OR FIGURING OUT HOW TO STOP
STUDENTS FROM BEING BLOCKED
FROM, YOU KNOW, GOING TO CLASS
AND, AND THEIR EDUCATION THAT
THEY'VE PAID FOR. AND THEY
DESERVE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT
EDUCATION SINCE THEY PAID FOR IT
. SO THANK YOU, I LOOK FORWARD
TO SUPPORTING YOU BOTH. AND I
THINK YOU, REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR BACKGROUND. AND YOU TOO,
REGENT LEE. SO THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, FOR THE TIME. THANK YOU,
MADAM VICE CHAIR. LET'S TURN
OVER TO SENATOR JONES. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR, I WANT TO THANK
THE OTHER MEMBERS ON THE
COMMITTEE AND THE REGENTS FOR
THEIR DISCUSSION REGARDING THE
FIRST AMENDMENT. I THINK YOU'RE
CATCHING FROM ALL OF US THAT
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT ISSUE, AND
I'M HOPEFUL THAT AS REGENTS, YOU
WILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THAT
LEADERSHIP TOWARDS THE
PROFESSORS THAT ON SOME OF OUR
CAMPUSES HAVE A MISUNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT THE FIRST AMENDMENT IS
AND HOW TO APPROPRIATELY APPLY
IT, WHICH IT SPECIFICALLY SAYS
IN ITS OWN LANGUAGE, PEACEFULLY,
PEACEABLY ASSEMBLE, I THINK
THAT'S HOW YOU STRIKE THE
BALANCE. YOU JUST COMPLY WITH
THE FIRST AMENDMENT. ONE OF THE
THINGS I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT,
TO MOVE ON THE DISCUSSION, IS
REGENT LEE, YOU SAID SOMETHING
IN OUR MEETING AND I WROTE IT
DOWN. MAJORS MATTER, AND I
REALLY APPRECIATED THAT, THAT
COMMENT BECAUSE AND AS I'VE BEEN
CONTEMPLATING IT, SINCE SINCE WE
HAD THAT DISCUSSION. SO IF I
COULD ASK BOTH OF YOU TO ADDRESS
TWO THINGS THAT I THINK ARE,
BECOMING A MORE AND MORE
IMPORTANT ISSUE WITH HIGHER
EDUCATION, NOT JUST IN
CALIFORNIA, BUT IN AMERICA
ITSELF IS, AS A REGENT. SO TWO,
TWO, TWO QUESTIONS. I THINK THEY
KIND OF THEY KIND OF GO TOGETHER
AT THE UC SYSTEM. AND I WOULD
EVEN ARGUE THAT THE CSU SYSTEM
ITSELF IS THERE. ARE WE AT A
POINT IN TIME WHERE WE NEED TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THE MAJORS THAT
ARE OFFERED AND BEGIN ANALYZING?
ARE ALL OF THEM NECESSARY, AND
ARE ALL OF THEM PROVIDING THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO STUDENTS AFTER
THEY GRADUATE WITH THOSE
WHATEVER, MAJOR. AND, YOU KNOW,
OBVIOUSLY, IT WOULD BE A
DEBATABLE TOPIC, TO, YOU KNOW,
MAYBE, ELIMINATE SOME OF THOSE
MAJORS THAT AREN'T PROVIDING THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT STUDENTS
THINK THEY'RE GOING TO PROVIDE.
AND THEN KIND OF IN LINE WITH
THAT, THERE'S A NATIONAL
DISCUSSION NOW ABOUT DEBT
FORGIVENESS FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION, WHICH TO ME
PERSONALLY IS VERY THAT'S VERY
OFFENSIVE, I'M A GRADUATE OF THE
CSU SYSTEM. I GRADUATED FROM SAN
DIEGO STATE. NOW, GRANTED 30
YEARS AGO WITH WITH NO STUDENT
DEBT. BUT TWO OF MY CHILDREN
HAVE GRADUATED FROM SAN DIEGO
STATE WITH UNDER $15,000 OF
DEBT. BUT THEY MADE SACRIFICES.
THEY MADE DECISIONS. THEY MADE.
THEY PASSED UP ON OPPORTUNITIES.
THEY YOU KNOW, TO AVOID GOING
INTO DEBT. AND MY YOUNGEST SON
ISN'T GOING TO GO TO A FOUR YEAR
COLLEGE. HE'S GRADUATED FROM
COMMUNITY COLLEGE, AND HE'S
CHOSEN A CAREER IN FIREFIGHTING
INSTEAD TO AVOID THAT LIFE
DECISION. RIGHT. THERE'S
MILLIONS OF FAMILIES IN THE
UNITED STATES THAT HAVE MADE
THAT DECISION ALSO TO NOT GO
INTO DEBT OR TO FIND A WAY TO
PAY IT OFF WITHOUT COUNTING ON
THE GOVERNMENT TO PAY IT OFF FOR
THEM OR FOR OR FORGIVE IT. SO IS
THERE A POINT IN TIME WHERE WE
HOLD THE INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION ACCOUNTABLE FOR SOME
OF THIS DEBT, EITHER THROUGH
THEIR FOUNDATIONS OR SOME OTHER?
TO ME, THE INSTITUTIONS ARE
GETTING OFF SCOT FREE WITH NO
CULPABILITY IN THIS DECISION
THAT THEY'RE TALKING THESE KIDS
INTO GOING INTO THIS. SO, SO TO
SUMMARIZE THE QUESTION, MAJORS,
DO WE IS THERE ARE WE AT A POINT
IN TIME WHERE WE NEED TO RELOOK
AT THOSE AND TO JUST YOUR
GENERAL ATTITUDE TOWARDS DEBT
FORGIVENESS? I PLEASE I CAN
START IF YOU'D LIKE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
QUESTION. I THINK THEY ARE
RELATED, BY THE WAY, IN TERMS OF
WHAT IS THE VALUE OF A UC DEGREE
AND WHAT I MENTIONED TO YOU IN
YOUR OFFICE FOR THE BENEFIT OF
EVERYONE ELSE, WAS THAT A UC
DEGREE? THE ROI OF A UC DEGREE
HAS BEEN PROVEN OVER THE COURSE
OF TEN YEARS, AND I JUST SAW A
STUDY FROM GEORGETOWN THAT
PROVED THIS, EVEN AS COMPARED TO
OTHER PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES, AS A
UC DEGREE IS TWICE AS VALUABLE
AND SO WE ARE GETTING THE RETURN
ON INVESTMENT TO ALLOW THESE
STUDENTS TO HAVE SOCIAL MOBILITY
FOR THE LONG TERM. BUT MAJORS DO
MATTER. AND WHAT YOU MAJOR IN,
AND THAT'S WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT
TO GET MORE STUDENTS INTO STEM
PROGRAMS, FOR EXAMPLE, BECAUSE
IT IS THERE ARE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE. THERE
ARE WAYS IN WHICH YOU CAN GROW
YOUR CAREER THAT MAY NOT BE
AVAILABLE IN OTHER MAJORS, SO
I'M NOT SURE I HAVE THE ANSWER
TO YOUR QUESTION OF WHETHER WE
SHOULD BE ELIMINATING PARTICULAR
MAJORS, BUT WHAT I DO KNOW IS
THAT HAVING THAT STEM EDUCATION
CAN BE CRITICAL FOR A YOUNG
STUDENT STARTING OUT. AND THEN
THE OTHER PART OF THAT IS ALSO
THAT INTERNSHIPS AND FIRST JOBS
MATTER. AND SO AGAIN, HOW DO WE
PROVIDE MORE RESOURCES FOR
CAREER COUNSELING SERVICES, AS
AN EXAMPLE, SO THAT ONCE A
STUDENT GRADUATES, HE OR SHE CAN
HAVE THAT FIRST JOB AND THEN BE
PUT ON THE RIGHT PATHWAY FOR THE
LONG TERM? I THINK IN TERMS OF
THE DEBT FORGIVENESS, THIS IS A
THE REASON WHY WE HAVE BEEN
FOCUSED ON PROVIDING A PATHWAY
FOR DEBT FREE EDUCATION AT UC,
AND I KNOW THAT HAS BEEN
CERTAINLY BEFORE OUR TIME, EVEN
BEEN A PRIORITY FOR EVERYONE,
INVOLVED IN THE HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM HERE IN CALIFORNIA. I
KNOW AGAIN, THE VALUE OF A UC
DEGREE EXISTS, BUT HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT OUR STUDENTS ARE
PROVIDED WITH ALL THE OPTIONS
AND THE BEST OPTIONS TO SET THEM
UP FOR SUCCESS? I TAKE OFF A
LITTLE BIT FROM WHAT REGENT LEE
SAID THE FOCUS THESE DAYS IS ALL
ON STEM, BUT WE HAVE TO REALLY
BE CAREFUL BECAUSE A LOT OF
THOSE TEXT JOBS ARE GOING TO
BECOME OBSOLETE VERY QUICKLY
WITH AI, AND PEOPLE ARE
FORGETTING THAT AND NOT THINKING
ABOUT LOOKING AHEAD. SCIENCE
PROGRAMS AND ALL OF THOSE ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT. THOSE ARE THE
JOBS WITH THE MONEY. WE HAVE TO
ALWAYS BEGIN. MAKE SURE THAT WE
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN MAJORS AND
REQUIREMENTS. SO ARE YOU GETTING
RID OF A MAJOR? ARE YOU GETTING
RID OF A CERTAIN REQUIREMENT
WHETHER YOU HAVE A AND I'M A
HUMANITIES PERSON, SO I'M GOING
TO ARGUE FOR THE ADVANTAGE OF
THE OF THE HUMANITIES. WELL,
IT'S FIRST OF ALL THE BEST MAJOR
FOR SOMEBODY WHO GOES INTO LAW.
AND I WOULD ARGUE SOMEBODY WHO
GOES INTO POLITICS BECAUSE YOU
KNOW, HOW TO DEBATE. SO I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THE WAYS, ONE OF
THE ADVANTAGES OF A DEGREE, FOR
INSTANCE, IN ENGLISH OR THE
HUMANITIES, BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
TAKE A POSITION IN ALL YOUR
PAPERS, YOU WRITE AND ARGUE IT
AND DEFEND IT BASED ON RESEARCH.
SO I THINK THERE'S REAL VALUE.
AND IF YOU CAN'T, IF YOU IF
YOU'RE TOTALLY FOCUSED ON STEM
AND YOU HAVE NOT FOCUSED ON YOUR
CRITICAL THINKING SKILLS USING
LANGUAGE, YOU'RE GOING TO BE
VULNERABLE IN THE POLITICAL AND
SOCIAL WORLDS. THE EXTENT TO
WHICH YOU HAVE THE FACILITY TO
USE AND UNDERSTAND LANGUAGE IS
YOUR FREEDOM. AND AGAIN, SO
IMPORTANT AND AN IMPERATIVE OF
AN EDUCATION, REGARDING THE, THE
DEBT SITUATION, AS I MENTIONED
IN YOUR OFFICE, WHAT FOR ME, YOU
KNOW, WHAT HAPPENED IS, OF
COURSE, THEIR MONEY WAS GIVEN,
OFFERED TO STUDENTS. AND THERE
ARE 18, 19, 20 YEARS OLD TO WHAT
EXTENT ARE THEY WERE THEY AWARE
OF WHAT THE CONSEQUENCES AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT BORROWING
THAT KIND OF MONEY MEANT? DID
THEY EVEN UNDERSTAND INTEREST
RATES? BUT AGAIN, WHO WAS TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THEM? AND I THINK
MAYBE WE COULD LEAVE IT RIGHT
THERE FOR NOW. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MR. JONES. YES,
PLEASE. MADAM VICE CHAIR, I
APOLOGIZE. I KNOW THAT WE
TALKED, REGENT LEE ABOUT PARGA.
YES. AND THE LAWSUIT THAT
HAPPENED TO HIT THE CSU SYSTEM
AND, AND THERE IS A LAWSUIT ON
THE DOCKET FOR THE UC SYSTEM.
NOW, I DID GET AN ANSWER THAT I
WANTED TO SHARE WITH YOU, IT'S
KIND OF, THERE IS A THERE IS A
DISPUTE GOING ON RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE, PARGA PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES AND PUBLIC ENTITIES
LIKE THE STATE SENATE AND THINGS
LIKE THAT, AND PUBLIC AGENCIES
ARE EXEMPT FROM PARGA AND THE
LEGISLATION AND THEN BUT THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION UNDER
ARTICLE NINE, SECTION NINE,
EXCLUDES THE UC SYSTEM. SO
HOPEFULLY THAT WILL SAVE US $1
BILLION IN TAXPAYER MONEY, BUT
WE SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT OUR
EMPLOYEES ARE TREATED RIGHT.
ABSOLUTELY. THERE WOULDN'T BE A
LAWSUIT TO BEGIN WITH. THANK
YOU. JUST JUST FOR THAT
REFERENCE, I WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT AND THEN I JUST HAVE A
COMMENT. I NOTICED THAT THE
HONORABLE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR IS
HERE. AND THEN I ALSO NOTICED
BEHIND THAT PILLAR OVER THERE IS
ONE OF THE MOST INCREDIBLE
PEOPLE THAT'S EVER WORKED IN
GOVERNMENT ON A MONT-AUX-SOURCES
. SO I'M WONDERING WHAT'S
HAPPENING TODAY. MR. CHAIR, ARE
YOU TALKING. WE FORGOT TO TELL
YOU. NO I'M KIDDING. NO NO NO
NO, I. MADAM LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR, WILL BE HERE TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
REGENTS HERE IN JUST A MOMENT.
YEAH, WHICH WE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE HERE. SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH. IT'S REALLY
GREAT TO HAVE YOU, MADAM
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR, IT'S GOOD
TO SEE YOU. AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, I'M JUST GOING TO I
JUST HAVE A FEW COMMENTS AND
THEN, JUST SOME QUESTIONS AND.
LOOK, I WILL ALWAYS VÌ BIAS IN
THE BEGINNING, FIRST AND
FOREMOST, I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO. I'LL ALWAYS CALL
HIM CHAIR SARRIS, AND HE REALLY
IS A TRAILBLAZER FOR, NOT JUST
HERE IN CALIFORNIA, BUT
THROUGHOUT THE NATION. AND WHAT
I APPRECIATE, REGENT SARRIS, IS
THAT YOU WEAR YOUR VALUES IN
YOUR SLEEVE, AND YOU COME UP
FROM BEYOND HUMBLE BEGINNINGS.
AND YOU SAW INCREDIBLE STRUGGLE
AS A KID. AND WHAT I TRULY
APPRECIATE ABOUT YOU IS THAT
WHEN YOU SEE AND YOU SAW
STRUGGLES AS A KID, YOU WANT TO
CHANGE IT AS AN ADULT, AND
YOU'VE SPENT YOUR ENTIRE ADULT
LIFE FIXING THAT FOR SO MANY
OTHERS AND GRATEFUL THAT YOU ARE
HERE TODAY, AND IT IS WONDERFUL.
REGENT LEE, TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
RYAN HERE TODAY, ALONG WITH YOUR
PARENTS. AND THEY MUST BE SO
INCREDIBLY PROUD. AND AN
AMERICAN SUCCESS STORY. YOU JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
STEPPING UP. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO, TALK A
BIT ABOUT THE CAMPUS CLIMATE,
AND I THINK IT'S ALL BEEN SAID,
BUT LOOK, IN OUR BACKYARD ON THE
NORTH COAST, WE HAVE SONOMA
STATE AND CAL POLY, HUMBOLDT.
AND I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE,
ALL STUDENTS OF ALL BACKGROUNDS
AND ALL FAITHS DESERVE TO BE
SAFE AND A CAMPUS COMMUNITY
THAT'S INCLUSIVE, AND IF WE'RE
BEING HONEST, THAT HAS NOT BEEN
THE CASE. AND IT'S NOT JUST
WITHIN THE UC SYSTEM, BUT WE SEE
THAT THE CSU SYSTEM AND CANDIDLY
, THROUGHOUT THE NATION AND WHAT
I APPRECIATE IS THAT YOUR CANDID
RESPONSE AND YOUR COMMITMENT TO
THAT, STATE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
PRESIDENT DRAKE, AS WE'VE
DISCUSSED IN THE PAST, AND
CHANCELLOR GARCIA FROM THE CSU
ON DEVELOPING THE LINE THAT
WHETHER CHANCELLORS OR
PRESIDENTS NEED TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE AT THEIR CAMPUS WHEN THEY
SEE DESTRUCTION OF SCHOOL
PROPERTY, INDIVIDUALS BLOCKING,
STUDENTS GOING TO AND FROM
CLASSES OR AROUND CAMPUS AND I
THINK IT'S BEEN A WAKE UP CALL.
AND PLEASE, I DON'T WANT TO PUT
WORDS INTO THE TWO OF YOUR
MOUTHS HERE, BUT IT'S BEEN A
WAKE UP CALL, I THINK, FOR THE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM TO BE ABLE TO
BE BETTER PREPARED. WHEN AND IF
WE SEE SUCH CHALLENGES POP UP ON
CAMPUSES, I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S ANYTHING YOU ALL WANT TO
MENTION ON THIS. AGAIN, I KNOW
WE'VE TALKED A LOT ABOUT IT, BUT
I WANTED TO BE ABLE TO OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY. I THINK THE WAKE UP
CALL IS THE RIGHT TERM. PRO TEM,
AND THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT. AND
LIKE I SAID BEFORE, I WAS GLAD
TO SEE, THAT IN RESPONSE TO THE
QUESTIONS THAT WE HAD AND THE
DEMANDS FOR CHANGES THAT WE HAD,
THAT THERE WAS, THERE WERE
ALREADY STEPS TAKEN IN ORDER TO
IMPROVE THE ENVIRONMENT AND FOR
US TO DO BETTER GOING FORWARD.
SO THANK YOU FOR THOSE FOR THOSE
OBSERVATIONS. I THINK IT WAS
CLEAR, ONE OF THE THINGS WE
LEARNED, I COULDN'T SAY IT
BETTER THAN CHANCELLOR BLOCK,
THAT IF WE HAD ENFORCED THE
POLICIES THAT ARE IN PLACE, FOR
INSTANCE, THE ENCAMPMENT THING,
WHAT FOLLOWED WOULD NOT HAVE
HAPPENED. AND WE'VE LEARNED THAT
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. I'D LIKE
TO SWITCH SUBJECTS. ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES, WHETHER IT'S
WITHIN THE UC SYSTEM, CSU SYSTEM
IS DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. WE HAVE
AGING CAMPUSES. ANY THOUGHTS ON
THAT? BECAUSE I KNOW THAT'S BEEN
AN ONGOING CHALLENGE FOR THE UC
SYSTEM. YEAH. AND IN PARTICULAR
SEISMIC CONCERNS AND GOES BACK
TO THE SAFETY OF OUR STUDENTS.
AND I KNOW WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO MAKE SOME TOUGH DECISIONS
COMING UP AND REBALANCING
PRIORITIES. AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE. BUT AGAIN, SAFETY BEING
THE FIRST AND FOREMOST. I MEAN,
THAT'S KIND OF HOW I THINK ABOUT
PRIORITIZING THINGS. YEAH, I
COULDN'T I CAN'T SAY ANYTHING
MORE THAN REGENT LEE, AGAIN,
SOME OF THE, THE AGING
STRUCTURES I WAS, I WAS AT UCLA
WHEN THE BIG EARTHQUAKE AND HALF
OF THE CAMPUS WAS UNUSABLE AFTER
THAT WAS 92, I BELIEVE, 92
EARTHQUAKE. THERE AND, TO THINK
THAT THE LUCKILY IT HAPPENED IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT. SENATOR
MCGUIRE. BUT IT HAD IT HAPPENED
DURING THE DAY. THERE WOULD HAVE
BEEN A LOT OF INJURIES, PERHAPS
DEATHS, BECAUSE THOSE OLD
BUILDINGS, THOSE BRICK BUILDINGS
WERE COULDN'T SUSTAIN THE SHAKE.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT STUDENT
HOUSING FOR A MOMENT, WE LOOK AT
THE NUMBER OF HOMELESS STUDENTS,
COMMUNITY COLLEGE, CSU, UCS
GROWING EACH AND EVERY YEAR. AND
IT'S OBVIOUSLY THE COST OF
HOUSING $3 BILLION THAT THE
STATE HAS ALLOCATED OVER THE
LAST 36 MONTHS. IT WAS SUCKED UP
IN A HOT MINUTE, AND THE NEED
OUTPACES, TRULY, WHAT THE
REALITY IS, IT'S BEEN SINCE
2006, SINCE THE UC AND CSU
SYSTEM HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN
EDUCATION. BOND. I THINK TIME IS
OF THE ESSENCE. WE OUGHT TO GET
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS INTO THE
SYSTEM. I KNOW THE UC SYSTEM IS
WORKING HARD TO BE ABLE TO COME
UP WITH UNIQUE STRATEGIES TO BE
ABLE TO FUND IT, BUT I THINK IF
WE'RE BEING HONEST, THERE IS NO
WAY YOU'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
HELP FUND THOSE LONG TERM
STUDENT HOUSING NEEDS WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL INFUSIONS OF CASH.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON STUDENT
HOUSING, AND ESPECIALLY THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS? YEAH, I
THINK I AGREE WITH YOU, YOU
KNOW, WHEN I WAS ON THE IRVINE
CAMPUS, I HEARD FROM A STUDENT
WHO WAS COMMUTING TWO HOURS EACH
WAY FROM HOME BECAUSE SHE
COULDN'T AFFORD TO LIVE ON
CAMPUS, AND THAT WAS HER
DECISION. SHE DIDN'T WANT TO
TAKE ON ADDITIONAL DEBT. BACK TO
THE DEBT POINT, IN ORDER TO HAVE
A ON CAMPUS HOUSING AS PART OF
HER EDUCATION. AND IT'S
TERRIBLE, HOW CAN WE PROVIDE
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR OUR
STUDENTS IN A TIMELY MANNER,
WORKING WITH OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS AND OTHERS? THOSE ARE
THE THINGS THAT WE NEED TO KEEP
IN MIND ALWAYS. AND THINKING
ABOUT THINGS LIKE THE ONLINE
CLASSES AND OTHER CREATIVE WAYS
WE CAN TRY TO SOLVE SOME OF
THESE PROBLEMS, AT LEAST IN THE
NEAR TERM. YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
HOPEFULLY LONG TENURES ON THIS
BOARD AND CAN THINK ABOUT THINGS
FOR THE LONG TERM AS WELL. BUT
AT LEAST IN THE SHORT TERM, HOW
DO WE SORT OF MINIMIZE THE HARM
HERE? AND THAT'S THE QUESTION.
LET ME TAKE IT BROADLY. THE
OTHER PROBLEM THAT WE'RE GOING
TO FACE IS ULTIMATELY AND YOU'VE
ALL KNOW BETTER AS WELL AS ME,
THAT ULTIMATELY YOU'RE GOING TO
GO IT'S TAX DOLLARS. AND WHEN
YOU SEE WHAT'S GOING ON ON
CAMPUS AND YOU HAVE THE VALUE OF
EDUCATION QUESTIONED, BECOMING
MORE BROAD AND BROAD, HOW ARE WE
GOING TO HAVE OUR PUBLIC WANT TO
KEEP FUNDING THIS UNIVERSITY AND
BE ABLE TO GET THAT MONEY?
THAT'S GOING TO BE AN ISSUE
GOING FORWARD, AND ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT
THE GOVERNOR WOULD LIKE TO SEE
IN TERMS OF NUMBERS, I THINK
IT'S APPROXIMATELY 160,000 MORE
STUDENTS, WE HAVE TO PAY FOR
THAT. SO AND IF YOU HAVE A
CONSTITUENCY, IF YOU HAVE A
VOTING BODY THAT HAS A VERY
NEGATIVE FEELING OR INCREASINGLY
NEGATIVE FEELINGS ABOUT THE
VALUE OF EDUCATION OR EVEN THE
PROFESSORS THERE, AND WHAT ARE
THEY TEACHING THEM, ALL THIS
KIND OF THING? IT'S GOING TO BE
A PROBLEM. SO IT'S AGAIN, OUR
JOB. I THINK MY JOB AS A REGENT
TO ONCE AGAIN, AND I HATE TO
SOUND LIKE A SAINT OR ANYTHING,
BUT IT'S OUR JOB ONCE AGAIN TO,
TALK ABOUT THE VALUE OF
EDUCATION AND TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEMS THAT ARE GOING ON NOW
REGARDING ALL THE PROTESTS AND
ALL OF THAT, SO THAT THE
EDUCATION, THE PUBLIC CAN SEE
THE VALUE OF THIS GREAT
UNIVERSITY ONCE AGAIN, 100. I
THINK THE BEST SYSTEM IN THE
NATION. CANDIDLY, ABSOLUTELY.
DESPITE CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE
SEEING. AND AGAIN, THIS ISN'T
ISOLATED TO THE GOLDEN STATE.
BUT DESPITE THE CHALLENGES, I
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE THE
BEST SYSTEM IN THIS IN THE
NATION. ALL RIGHT. WE'D LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO SEE BEFORE WE TURN IT
OVER TO MADAM LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR, WHO WILL KICK US OFF
HERE TODAY. WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT. SO WHAT
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO IS
WE'RE GOING TO BE GOING TO THE
PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION OF
TODAY'S HEARING. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT
MADAM LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR IS
HERE. MADAM LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR,
WE WELCOME YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR TAKING TIME OUT OF YOUR
BUSY SCHEDULE. IT'S WONDERFUL TO
SEE YOU. THE FLOOR IS YOURS,
MA'AM. WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME, MADAM VICE CHAIR. IT'S
WONDERFUL TO BE HERE. I'M HERE
IN SUPPORT OF BOTH OF THESE
CANDIDATES AND HOPE THAT TODAY
YOU WILL CONFIRM THEM AS OUR
NEWEST MEMBERS OF THE UC BOARD
OF REGENTS. I'M VERY PROUD THAT
IN ADDITION TO SERVING OR AS
PART OF MY DUTY DUTIES AS
SERVING AS LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR,
I'M THE ONLY PERSON TO SIT ON
ALL THREE BOARDS OF PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. VÀ AND I SPEND MANY,
MANY HOURS EVERY MONTH ATTENDING
THESE MEETINGS, AND I'M HERE TO
ATTEST THAT BOTH OF THESE
CANDIDATES HAVE ALREADY
CONTRIBUTED IN THE LAST YEAR. IN
THE CASE OF REGENT HARRIS, A
GREAT DEAL OF TIME IN
PARTICIPATING IN THESE MEETINGS,
BRINGING THEIR EXPERTISE AND
THEIR EXPERIENCE TO THE TABLE AT
A TIME WHERE WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING OVERTIME AT THE UC
REGENTS TO DEAL WITH SO MANY
PARTICULAR ISSUES, I ALSO WOULD
LIKE JUST TO CALL OUT THE WORK
OF BOTH OF THESE CANDIDATES
PRIOR TO EVEN BEING NOMINATED TO
SERVE AT AN AS MEMBERS OF THE
REGENTS. IN THE CASE OF REGENT
LEE, SHE SERVED ON THE BOARD OF
ÁP SCHOLARS, THE NATION'S
LARGEST NONPROFIT IN SUPPORT OF
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER SCHOLAR
SHIPS. AND OF COURSE, THIS HAS
BEEN NOTED. SHE HERSELF BRINGS
THE EXPERIENCE OF AN
EXTRAORDINARY CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT SUCCESS STORY,
IMMIGRANT FAMILY SUCCESS STORY.
AND IN THE CASE OF REGENT SARIS,
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT IF CONFIRMED, HE WILL BE
THE VERY FIRST NATIVE AMERICAN
FROM CALIFORNIA TO SERVE AS A UC
REGENT AND IN THE PAST, HIS
COMMITMENT TO THIS UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM HAS BEEN EXTRAORDINARY.
CHAIRMAN SARIS WAS INSTRUMENTAL
IN SETTING UP THE NATIVE
AMERICAN OPPORTUNITY PLAN AT THE
UC, A PROGRAM THAT COVERS
TUITION AND FEES FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS FROM FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES. AND IN
ADDITION, HIS TRIBE, THE
FEDERATED INDIANS OF GRATON
RANCHERIA, PROVIDES SCHOLARSHIPS
FOR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS FROM
NON-FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
CALIFORNIA TRIBES, ENSURING
ACCESS TO THIS BENEFIT FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA'S TRIBAL COMMUNITIES.
SO WITH THAT, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SAY
A FEW WORDS, AND I HOPE TO SEE
THE CONFIRMATION OF BOTH OF
THESE CANDIDATES TODAY. THANK
YOU, MADAM LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR,
IT'S WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU.
WONDERFUL TO SEE YOUR YOUR TEAM
AS WELL. THANK YOU. SO MUCH.
WE'RE GRATEFUL. WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO DO IS WE'RE GOING TO NOW OPEN
IT UP TO ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. WHAT WE'RE GOING TO ASK
IF YOU COULD PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR
FIRST AND LAST NAME THE
ORGANIZATION THAT YOU'RE
REPRESENTING. PLEASE. IT'S GOOD
TO SEE YOU, SIR. MR. CHAIRMAN,
MEMBERS, AARON REED REPRESENTING
MYSELF, I HAVE KNOWN CHAIRMAN
SARRIS FOR 12 YEARS. HE HIRED
OUR FIRM WHEN HE WAS TRYING TO
GET HIS VERY FIRST COMPACT
RATIFIED IN ORDER TO BUILD THE
NEW, BEAUTIFUL CASINO THAT THEY
ENDED UP BUILDING. WHEN WE
STARTED, EVERYBODY WAS OPPOSED,
BUT GREG HAD ENERGY, ENTHUSIASM,
AND HE AND HE WORKED ON BRINGING
THEM AROUND. AND THROUGH THAT
PROCESS, EVERYBODY THAT WAS ONCE
OPPOSED TO THE CASINO AND
OPPOSED EVEN TO THE BILL HAS NOW
THEY NOW BELIEVE THAT THEY
CREATED IT, THAT IT WAS THEIR
IDEA. THAT'S HOW EFFECTIVE
CHAIRMAN SARRIS IS, IS, I MEAN,
HE CONVINCED THEM OF THE VALUE
AND HIS ENERGY AND ENTHUSIASM
AND GENEROSITY IS ABOVE ALL, ALL
OTHERS. AND I JUST THAT'S OFTEN
LOST. BUT I SEE IT ON A DAILY
BASIS BECAUSE WE'RE ABLE TO WORK
WITH HIS TRIBE TODAY. SO YOU
COULDN'T FIND A MORE
ENTHUSIASTIC, ENERGETIC MEMBER
OF THE REGENTS. AND EDUCATION
FOR HIM IS EVERY BIT THE PASSION
THAT BEING THE TRIBAL CHAIR HAS
BEEN FOR HIM. SO IT'S A PASSION
THAT I ADMIRE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MR. REED. IT'S GOOD
TO SEE YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON,
MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS. TRENT
SMITH HERE, SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE WALT DISNEY COMPANY IN
FAVOR OF NANCY LEE'S
CONFIRMATION, SHE IS. THE WALT
DISNEY COMPANY HAS BENEFITED
GREATLY FROM HER SERVICE FOR
MANY, MANY YEARS, AND THEY'RE
EXCITED WITH THE IDEA OF HER
SERVING THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
VÀ AND THE STUDENTS OF THE UC
SYSTEM, AND THEY WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT HER CONFIRMATION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
SMITH. WE'RE GRATEFUL WE'RE
GOING TO DO A LAST CALL, LAST
CALL FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE IN
SUPPORT. LAST CALL FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT. IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ADVANCE AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT.
HEARING SEEING NONE, WE'RE NOW
GOING TO WELCOME ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. WE'RE LOOKING FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION.
WE'RE GOING TO DO A LAST CALL
FOR OPPOSITION. IF YOU COULD
PLEASE STEP FORWARD HEARING
SEEING NONE, WE'RE NOW GOING TO
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
WE'RE GOING TO LOOK TO COMMITTEE
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE TO MOVE
BOTH NOMINEES TO THE FLOOR. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MADAM VICE
CHAIR TO BE ABLE TO MOVE REGENT
LEE REGENT SARRIS TO THE FLOOR.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL? MCGUIRE. AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE GROVE. GROVE. AYE.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE. JONES.
JONES. AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD AYE. 5
TO 0. LOOK AT THAT FIVE ZERO
VOTE. CONGRATULATIONS. NEXT UP
WILL BE THE SENATE FLOOR. THANK
YOU SO MUCH TO BOTH OF YOU.
WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. REGENT SERIES. THANK YOU,
REGENT LEE. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
A 32ND 32ND READ. JUST MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE ALL GOOD. 32ND
RECESS. IN THE MEANTIME, WE'RE
GOING TO WELCOME UP MR. PAULSON.
MR. PAULSON, IF YOU WANT TO COME
ON FORWARD 32ND, 32ND RECESS.
ALL RIGHT. WELCOME BACK, LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN. WE NOW HAVE ITEM
ONE C LOU PAULSON. PAULSON, IT'S
SO WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYEE RELATIONS BOARD.
ONE OF THE MORE THANKLESS JOBS
TRULY, AND SO INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, MR. PAULSON, YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE 1 OR 2 MINUTES TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY,
WE'RE THEN GOING TO OPEN IT UP
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
CONVERSATION. ANY DEBATE THAT
MAY ENSUE IN YOUR OPENING. WE
OFFER YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO
WELCOME ANY GUESTS WHO ARE HERE
WITH YOU TODAY OR WATCHING
ONLINE, WE'LL BE KEEPING TIME.
I'LL GIVE YOU A 32ND PROMPT.
PAULSON. ALWAYS WONDERFUL TO BE
IN YOUR PRESENCE, SIR. YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU. SENATOR, I'LL BE
BRIEF. I KNOW IT'S A LONG DAY
FOR YOU. I JUST WANT TO, LET THE
COMMITTEE KNOW HOW HONORED I WAS
TO BE APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR
NEWSOM AND TO SERVE MY FIRST
TERM. AND I WILL AGAIN
DISTINCTLY HONORED. I WAS TO BE
REAPPOINTED AND OBVIOUSLY
LOOKING FORWARD TO SERVING
ANOTHER TERM. IF YOU FOLKS AGREE
WITH AGREE WITH THAT, I SERVE
WITH A GREAT GROUP OF PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES AND I THINK IT'S A LOT
OF TIMES WE OVERLOOK THOSE
FOLKS. BUT THE STAFF AT PERM
DOES UNBELIEVABLE WORK. THEY
COULD GO WORK ELSEWHERE, BUT
THEY DECIDE TO DO PUBLIC
SERVICE, AND WE'RE GREATLY
APPRECIATIVE OF ALL OF THEM FOR
THE WORK THAT THEY DO, AND THEN
FINALLY, I'D JUST LIKE TO THANK,
THE GOVERNOR'S STAFF, SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE STAFF, ALL OF
YOUR STAFFS FOR TAKING TIME FOR
ME. I KNOW RULES, HAS A LOT
APPOINTMENTS, HAS A LOT OF WORK
TO DO, BUT THEY MADE IT ABOUT ME
EVERY TIME THAT WE TALKED. AND I
APPRECIATED ALL THAT TIME THAT
THEY GAVE TO ME, PREPARING ME
FOR TODAY. AND THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MR. PAULSON. WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO IS OPEN IT UP
FOR QUESTIONS, COMMENTS, ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE. IF WE HAVE ANY MEMBER,
PLEASE. SENATOR EGGMAN, THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE. MR. PAULSON.
SORRY WE DIDN'T GET TO MEET. I
HAD TO BAIL AT THE LAST MINUTE,
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT. BUT I
WANTED TO ASK YOU. JUST LIKE. SO
YOU'RE. I KNOW I'VE KNOWN YOU
FOR A LONG TIME. YOU'VE HAD A
LIFETIME CAREER IN PUBLIC
SERVICE AND NOW RETIRED. AND NOW
DOING THIS. SO WHAT DRAWS YOU TO
THIS AND WHAT'S GOING TO KEEP
YOU FOR ROUND TWO? WHAT IS IT
ABOUT THIS THAT IS EXCITING?
AFTER BEING A FIREFIGHTER? WELL,
IT, MY JOKE IS THERE'S NO REAL
EMERGENCIES AT PERB, SO THAT'S
ONE THING THAT MAKES LIFE A
LITTLE EASIER, BUT I ENJOY THE
WORK. IT'S VERY CHALLENGING, I
THINK WE HAVE A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY AT PERB, AND WE HAVE
BEEN DOING A LOT OF WORK TO BE
INSTRUCTIVE TO OUR LABOR
MANAGEMENT PARTNERS AND TO OUR
UNIONS TO BE ABLE TO GET GOOD
LABOR MANAGEMENT RELATIONSHIPS.
I THINK THE WORK, AGAIN, IT'S
VERY CHALLENGING. WE GET SOME
VERY INTERESTING QUESTIONS,
PEOPLE RELY ON US AND OUR
EXPERTISE AND OUR THOUGHTFULNESS
, THEY MAY NOT ALWAYS AGREE WITH
US, I UNDERSTAND THAT, BUT BUT
WE DO DELIBERATE BIG ISSUES AND
IT'S VERY REWARDING WORK. AND I
SERVE AGAIN. I SERVE WITH A
GREAT GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT I'M
AMAZING TO BE ASSOCIATED WITH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, THANK YOU
SO MUCH. PLEASE, SENATOR LAIRD,
FIRST IT WAS IT WAS GREAT TO
MEET WITH YOU AND HAVE A GREAT
CHAT AND, AND YOUR POOR STAFFER
WAS THE ONLY ONE THAT DIDN'T
HAVE ONE PARTICULAR CONNECTION
IN HIS PAST LIFE. SO THAT WAS A
GOOD MOMENT. ONE OF THE THINGS
YOU SAID WAS, YOU AND I WAS
INTRIGUED BECAUSE YOU SAID,
WELL, WE HAVE TO REALLY PAY MORE
ATTENTION TO THE DATA, AND WE'RE
UPGRADING OUR INFORMATION SYSTEM
AND WHEN WE DO THAT, WE WILL
HAVE MORE OF A CHANCE. COULD YOU
TALK ABOUT THAT A LITTLE? YES.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS, HAVING
SERVED ON THE UC BERKELEY LABOR
CENTER, I'M ALWAYS CONCERNED AND
DONE SOME TEACHING AROUND LABOR
MANAGEMENT RELATIONS. I'M ALWAYS
CONCERNED ABOUT IT'S JUST NOT
THE INSTANT CASE THAT GETS
BEFORE US. BUT REALLY, THE
CULTURE THAT DRIVES THOSE CASES
TO US, AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON WITH
OUR NEW ELECTRONIC PROCESSING IS
BEING ABLE TO GET SOME DATA,
SOME REAL DATA THAT WE CAN LOOK
AT AND MAYBE DO SOME RESEARCH ON
SOME CASES. BUT ADDITIONALLY,
THE, THE BIGGER POINT IS THE
CASELOAD HAS ALWAYS BEEN GREAT.
ONE OF THE BIG CONSTERNATIONS.
AND QUITE FRANKLY, WHEN I WAS
UNION PRESIDENT, WE THREW ROCKS
AT PERB FOR NOT MOVING THINGS
FAST ENOUGH, BUT COME TO FIND
OUT, GETTING THE SAME ROCKS NOW.
YES I'M CHECKING. I'M JUST. I'M
WEAVING AND BOBBING A LITTLE
BETTER THESE DAYS, BUT, ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE FINALLY HAVE
DECIDED SINCE WE'VE GOTTEN THE
CASELOAD DOWN FROM WHEN I CAME
ON, THERE WERE 92 CASES ON THE
DOCKET. WE'RE RIGHT AT 20 TODAY,
WE ARE STARTING TO REALIZE THAT
IT'S JUST NOT THE NUMBERS. SOME
OF THESE CASES ARE VERY NOT
NECESSARILY ROUTINE, BUT DON'T
TAKE A LOT OF TIME, BUT SOME OF
THEM TAKE QUITE A BIT OF TIME. I
HAD A CASE THAT TOOK OVER SIX
MONTHS FOR US TO GET TO A
DECISION. I'VE HAD CASES WHERE
WE CAME TO A DECISION AND THE
PARTIES SETTLED, AND THE WHOLE
THING WAS DISMISSED. THOSE ARE
JUST NUMBERS, BUT THEY'RE NOT
REALLY REFLECTIVE ACCURATELY ON
THE TIME THAT WE'RE USING TO
DELIBERATE THOSE. SO I THINK WE
NEED TO COME COME BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE, ESPECIALLY AROUND
BUDGET TIMES, AS WE TALK TO YOU
ABOUT THE WORK THAT WE DO AND BE
REAL SERIOUS ABOUT. IT'S JUST
NOT NUMBERS. IT'S THE AMOUNT OF
TIME THAT WE'RE SPENDING ON SOME
OF THESE CASES. AND SOME OF
THESE QUESTIONS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO LABOR MANAGEMENT
RELATIONSHIPS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AT EVERY LEVEL. AND
THEY TAKE A LOT OF TIME TO
DELIBERATE AND GET TO A
CONCLUSION. AND THEN THE OTHER
QUESTION, WE HAD A CHANCE TO
TALK ABOUT A LOT OF THINGS, BUT
WE HAD A CHANCE TO TALK ABOUT
THE FACT THAT IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS, THE LEGISLATURE HAS
ASSIGNED DIFFERENT TRANSIT
SYSTEMS TO PERB TO BE THE
ARBITRATOR OR THE MEDIATOR. AND
I WAS JUST ASKING BECAUSE A LOT
OF THEM HAVE BEEN ADDED SINCE
YOU WERE APPOINTED TO PERB.
HOW'S THAT GOING? YEAH WE
ACTUALLY SINCE WE TALKED, WE RAN
THE NUMBERS JUST TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE ACCURATE. SO WE'VE HAD
THREE TRANSIT CHARGES FILED THIS
YEAR, IN THE PAST FIVE YEARS
SINCE I'VE CAME ON, WE'VE HAD 29
TOTAL. SO NOT A LOT OF WORK. IT
TRANSIT IS A CHALLENGE BECAUSE
IT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT ANIMAL
FROM WHAT WE NORMALLY SEE, BUT
WE'VE SEEN ALSO THAT IT'S BEEN
ABLE TO, HAVE A QUIETING EFFECT,
HAVING THEM BE ABLE TO COME TO
PERB TO DEAL WITH SOME ISSUES.
GREAT. THANK YOU. APPRECIATE
YOUR SERVICE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. SENATOR LAIRD, ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
DISCUSSION FROM THE COMMITTEE?
ALL RIGHT. WHAT WE'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO DO IS WELCOME ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF MR.
PAULSON. IF YOU COULD PLEASE
COME FORWARD FIRST AND LAST NAME
ORGANIZATION AND 30S. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS. MEGAN
SUPERS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS, WE WOULD LIKE TO
EXTEND OUR OUR GREAT DEEP
SUPPORT FOR BOARD MEMBER PAULSON
ON BEHALF OF OUR 35,000 MEMBERS
AND OUR PRESIDENT, AS YOU HEARD,
GREAT UNION LEADER LOCALLY, BUT
ALSO A GREAT UNION LEADER FOR 14
YEARS OF THE CPF, WE THINK HE
HAS THE WHEREWITHAL TO SUPPORT
GOOD LABOR VOICE, BUT ALSO FAIR,
WE WERE OFTEN THROWING ROCKS AT
PERB OVER LACK OF RESOURCES,
BACKLOG OF CASELOAD. WE HAVE
SEEN SUCH GREAT IMPROVEMENT OVER
THE LAST EIGHT, 6 TO 8 YEARS,
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
ALL THE BOARD MEMBERS AND WOULD,
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT AT THE
RIGHT TIME. THANK YOU. IT'S GOOD
TO SEE YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, YVONNE FERNANDES WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION,
ALSO SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF MR.
PAULSON AND HIS REAPPOINTMENT TO
THE PERB BOARD, I ECHO THE WORDS
THAT WERE MENTIONED BY MY
COLLEAGUE MEGAN ZUBIATE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS. AND WE ARE VERY
EAGER FOR THE EFFECTIVENESS AND
EFFICIENCY THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
BE ON THE BOARD FOR PERB. SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE. WE'RE GOING
TO DO A LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO
MAY MAY SPEAK IN SUPPORT THOSE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. IF YOU COULD PLEASE
COME FORWARD NOW WE'RE GOING TO
TRANSITION TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION, CAN YOU PLEASE
ADVANCE AT THIS TIME, HEARING
AND SEEING NO ONE RISE, WE'RE
GOING TO BRING YOU BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE, IS THERE A MOTION?
I'LL MAKE THE MOTION. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR JONES. MADAM
SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL? MCGUIRE. AYE. MCGUIRE.
AYE. GROVE EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE.
JOAN A JONES. AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD.
AYE ON CALL. THAT'S A40 VOTE
THUS FAR. FOUR ZERO VOTE. AND WE
ARE GOING TO BE ON CALL. MR.
PAULSON AND WHAT WE'LL DO IS
ALLOW FOR SENATOR GROVE TO BE
ABLE TO ADD ON WHEN SHE GETS
BACK FROM HEALTH COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MR. PAULSON. IT'S WONDERFUL TO
SEE YOU. GOOD TO SEE YOU. WELL,
ON YOUR WAY TO ADDITIONAL
CONFIRMATION AND THEN ON TO THE
SENATE FLOOR FOR FINAL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU ALL. REALLY APPRECIATE IT,
SIR. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. WE
HAVE ONE OF THE MOST PATIENT
INDIVIDUALS HERE IN THE
AUDIENCE. AND THAT'S DANIEL
BERLAND. DANIEL BERLAND IS UP
FOR STATE FIRE MARSHAL, THROUGH
CAL FIRE, ALSO KNOWN AS
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION. MR. BERLAND, THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE SERVICE TO
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
ALSO WANT TO WELCOME CHIEF TYLER
AND SO MANY, WOMEN AND MEN FROM
CAL FIRE HERE TODAY AS WELL. MR.
BERLAND, YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE 1
OR 2 MINUTES FOR OPENING
TESTIMONY, THEN WE'RE GOING TO
OPEN IT UP FOR THE COMMITTEE TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS TO YOU IN YOUR
OPENING. WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO BE
ABLE TO WELCOME ANY GUESTS THAT
YOU MAY HAVE HERE, EITHER IN
PERSON OR WATCHING ONLINE. AND
THEN, IF IT WORKS, I'LL GIVE YOU
A 32ND PROMPT AS YOU GET CLOSE
TO TWO MINUTES. SIR THANK YOU SO
MUCH. IT'S WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU
SERVE. THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU. CHAIR MCGUIRE. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. FIRST, I'D LIKE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE MY WIFE, KRISTEN.
MY THREE YEAR OLD, JACKSON, MY
PARENTS, MIKE AND DEBBIE. MY
STEPMOM, SUE. NONE OF WHICH
COULD MAKE IT HERE. IN FACT, MY
WIFE IS PROBABLY BUSY TEACHING
HER CLASS, AND SO SHE HAS HER
HANDS FULL, AND PROBABLY NOT
WATCHING, BUT I KNOW WE'LL WATCH
LATER. I'M ABSOLUTELY HONORED TO
HAVE BEEN APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR TO THIS POSITION. AND
SO THANKFUL FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THIS AFTERNOON. AS
MENTIONED TODAY, I'M JOINED BY
CAL FIRE DIRECTOR JOE TYLER, OUR
CHIEF DEPUTY, AND LEE BURLEW,
SEVERAL RETIRED STATE FIRE
MARSHALS, LOCAL BUILDING AND
FIRE OFFICIALS, AND THEN MANY OF
THE PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS THAT
WE WORK WITH EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND THEN BACK AT THE OFFICE,
THOUGH THEY ARE BUSY WORKING, I
KNOW MANY OF OUR TEAM MEMBERS
FROM THE OFFICE OF STATE FIRE
MARSHAL ARE WATCHING AS WE
SPEAK. YOU KNOW, I'VE SPENT MY
ENTIRE CAREER WORKING IN FIRE
PREVENTION AND IN EFFORTS TO
REDUCE FIRE, PREPARE PEOPLE FOR,
FOR THESE TYPE OF DISASTERS, AS
WELL AS TEN YEARS IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SITTING ON A CITY
COUNCIL FOR NEARLY A DECADE. AND
SO THIS COMBINATION OF THESE TWO
POSITIONS GIVES ME, I THINK, A
UNIQUE INSIGHT, INTO THE
CHALLENGES THAT OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ARE FACING, RELEVANT
TO TOPICS LIKE FIRE INSURANCE,
HOUSING AVAILABILITY AND LOCAL
CONTROL. THE EXPERIENCES, THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS, THE CHALLENGES,
ALL OF THESE WHICH WHICH I HAVE
FACED DURING MY CAREER IN
ADDITION TO MY PERSONAL
COMMITMENTS TO COMMUNICATION AND
CUSTOMER SERVICE, HAVE, PREPARED
ME WELL FOR THE IMPORTANT TASK
OF SERVING ALL CALIFORNIANS AS
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL. SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO ANSWERING ALL
YOUR QUESTIONS, BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY, TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH ALL OF YOU IN MAKING SURE
CALIFORNIA IS A BETTER PREPARED
STATE WHEN IT COMES TO
WILDFIRES. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MR. BERLANT. WE'RE GRATEFUL
WE'RE GOING TO KICK OFF WITH
SENATOR LAIRD, AND THEN WE'LL
OPEN IT UP FOR THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE. SENATOR LAIRD, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. CHAIR. AND IT IT'S
KIND OF SILLY TO QUESTION
SOMEBODY I WORKED WITH FOR EIGHT
YEARS AS IF I DON'T KNOW YOU AND
, YOU KNOW, I ALWAYS APPRECIATED
YOUR PERFORMANCE AND YOUR GOOD
JOB, WITH THE POSSIBLE EXCEPTION
OF YOU NEEDING YOUR HEAD
EXAMINED, WANTING TO BE A CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER, AND, BUT I THINK
I'LL ASK ABOUT A COUPLE OF AREAS
THAT I THINK ARE GOOD. AND WE
TALKED WHEN WE MET ABOUT JUST
YOUR HOME HARDENING RETROFIT
PROGRAM AND, AND THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE YOU'VE SERVED, WHAT
YOU'VE DONE. AND WE ARE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT FIRE
INSURANCE, OBVIOUSLY. AND THAT
IS ONE OF THE PIECES THAT'S ON
THE TABLE. SO COULD YOU TELL US
HOW THAT'S GOING, HOW MANY
YOU'VE DONE, WHAT YOU SORT OF
SEE FOR THAT PROGRAM GOING
FORWARD? YEAH JUST TAKING A STEP
BACK HOME. HARDING HAS REALLY
BEEN AROUND SINCE 2008, WHEN THE
STATE PASSED BUILDING CODE
REQUIREMENTS FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION TO BE BUILT OUT OF
BUILDING MATERIALS THAT WERE
EMBER AND IGNITION RESISTANT.
BUT IN IN THE WAKE OF THE NEARLY
60,000 HOMES AND BUILDINGS THAT
HAVE BEEN DESTROYED BY FIRES, WE
HAVE FOUND THROUGH,
UNFORTUNATELY, THAT DEVASTATION,
IN ADDITION TO OUR RESEARCH,
THAT THE COMBINATION OF
RETROFITTING HOMES WITH
DEFENSIBLE SPACE SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASES THE HOME'S CHANCE OF
SURVIVING A WILDFIRE. THE
CHALLENGE, THOUGH, THAT WE HAVE
ARE 90% OF THE HOMES IN WILDFIRE
PRONE AREAS WERE BUILT BEFORE
THIS CODE. SO HOW DO WE RETROFIT
THOSE THOSE HOMES? BUT MORE
SPECIFICALLY, THE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS OF CALIFORNIA, THOSE
WHO CAN'T AFFORD TO DO THIS
WORK, WHO CAN'T PHYSICALLY DO
THIS WORK, THOSE INDIVIDUALS
NEED THIS WORK DONE TO THEIR
HOMES JUST AS MUCH AS ANYBODY
ELSE. AND SO WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING FOR THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS WITH CAL OES TO BUILD A
HOME HARDENING FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM, AND WHILE IT
LEVERAGES UPWARDS OF 90% FEDERAL
DOLLARS, THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT
OF LESSONS LEARNED AND BARRIERS,
IF YOU WILL, THAT WE'VE WORKED
TO OVERCOME. IN FACT, SENATOR
MCGUIRE, I'M EXCITED TO SAY THAT
THE FIRST HOME TO BE RETROFITTED
IS IN LAKE COUNTY AND IS UNDER
CONSTRUCTION IN THE FIRST
COUPLE, BUT IT'S A COUNTY THAT
BURNED 53% OVER A NUMBER OF
FIRES IN A FEW YEARS. YEAH LAKE
COUNTY HAS SEEN ITS FAIR SHARE
OF WILDFIRES IN THIS COMMUNITY
THAT WE'RE HARDING AND WE
SPECIFICALLY CHOSE BECAUSE ONE,
IT IS NOT AN AREA THAT SAW ANY
OF THE MAJOR WILDFIRES, BUT IT
ALSO HAS A DENSITY THAT WE
REALLY WANT TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
IS THE RIGHT NUMBER TO ENSURE
THAT WE HARDEN ENOUGH HOMES SO
THAT IF ONE CATCHES ON FIRE,
THAT OR A FIRE, EMBERS GET INTO
THAT NEIGHBORHOOD THAT IF ONE
CATCHES ON FIRE, THE REST ARE
STILL, IF YOU WILL IMMUNE, TO,
TO A CONFLAGRATION THAT HOME
HARDENING PROGRAM AGAIN IS
FINALLY STARTING TO SEE SOME
SUCCESS. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
REPORTING BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THOSE SUCCESSES,
BUT ALSO THOSE BARRIERS, AND
THEN TO CONTINUE TO SCALE UP
THIS PROGRAM AND THIS PILOT THAT
WE HAVE TO GET TO UPWARDS OF
2500 HOMES OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
OF YEARS. AND IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT YOU'VE PUT TOGETHER
ALREADY? YOU JUST DON'T HAVE THE
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE,
BECAUSE IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS,
IT MIGHT BE OF VALUE TO SOME OF
US THAT ARE WORKING ON SOME
THINGS. YEAH. OUR LEGISLATIVE
TIMELINE IS BY JULY, AND SO YOU
SHOULD BE GETTING SOMETHING HERE
VERY, VERY SOON. THAT AGAIN
SUMMARIZES THE PROGRAM, THE
FRAMEWORK THAT WE HAVE BUILT,
BUT THEN ADDRESSES THE BARRIERS.
REMEMBER, THIS IS A PILOT
PROGRAM THAT THAT WAS SET
THROUGH STATUTE AND IS PART OF
THAT PILOT. AGAIN, WE WERE
TASKED WITH TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO NOT ONLY PUT TOGETHER
THIS PROGRAM, BUT ALSO TO
IDENTIFY THOSE CHALLENGES AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY, ACCESS THE
FEDERAL DOLLARS. AGAIN, WE'RE SO
EXCITED TO BE ABLE TO REACH
UPWARDS OF 90% OF FEDERAL
DOLLARS TO MATCH THE STATE
INVESTMENT IN THIS PROGRAM. BUT
THAT COMES AT CHALLENGES. AND SO
THE SHORT ANSWER THAT WAS A VERY
LONG WAY, SENATOR, SAYING, YES,
YOU'LL GET A REPORT, HOPEFULLY
WITHIN THIS NEXT MONTH THAT THAT
ANSWERS SOME OF THOSE QUESTIONS.
FIRST TO ME, ARE YOU JUST IN THE
COURSE OF DOING THIS, KEEPING UP
WITH LIKE, TECHNOLOGY
IMPROVEMENTS OR WHAT? YOU MIGHT
NOT HAVE PERSONALLY THROUGH THE
PROGRAM RETROFITTED, BUT YOU
HAVE SEEN IN SOME FIRES WITH
PEOPLE THAT MIGHT HAVE DONE IT
OUTSIDE THE PROGRAM. WE ARE
CONSTANTLY, ACCESSING THE LATEST
RESEARCH AND SCIENCE AND
BRINGING THAT INTO ONE. OUR
BUILDING CODES. SO NEW HOMES ARE
USING THE NEW TECHNOLOGIES,
NEWEST MATERIALS, BUT ALSO
CONTINUOUSLY ADDING THAT INTO
THE RETROFIT PROGRAM AS WELL.
AND SO WHILE IT'S TAKEN A COUPLE
OF YEARS TO GET OFF THE GROUND,
SOME OF THE ITEMS BEING
RETROFITTED AND SOME OF THE
TECHNOLOGIES OR THE BUILDING
MATERIALS THAT WILL BE
RETROFITTING THOSE HOMES WITH
HAS DEFINITELY CHANGED EVEN IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS. WELL,
SENATOR DOLLY AND I LED A TOUR
TO HIS DISTRICT. HE DIDN'T NEED
THE TOUR. BUT WHEN WE MET TO THE
TOWN OF GREENVILLE THAT
COMPLETELY BURNED DOWN. THERE
ARE TWO EXPERIMENTAL HOMES BEING
BUILT THAT THAT, ARE DESIGNED TO
BE IN THE MIDDLE OF A FIRESTORM
AND, AND GO FOR TWO HOURS
WITHOUT IGNITING. AND IT WAS
FASCINATING TO SEE EVERYTHING
YOU HAD TO DO TO DO THAT. AND I
JUST WONDERED IF THINGS LIKE
THAT YOU'RE FOLLOWING ON OR
INCORPORATING INTO TO WHAT
YOU'RE AFTER. YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH A
NUMBER OF RESEARCH GROUPS, THE
INSURANCE INSTITUTE FOR BUSINESS
AND HOME SAFETY, THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE FOR STANDARDS AND
TECHNOLOGY ARE REALLY TWO OF THE
LEADERS IN THIS SPACE. AND WE
ARE CONSTANTLY PARTNERING WITH
THEM TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING THAT OR TAKING
ACCESSING THAT. THE RESULTS OF
THAT RESEARCH AND THEN EMBEDDING
IT IN WORKING WITH OUR BUILDING
INDUSTRY, WORKING WITH OUR
BUILDING OFFICIALS AND OUR LOCAL
FIRE OFFICIALS TO, AGAIN,
CONSTANTLY UPDATE THE CODES SO
THAT THEY'RE INCORPORATING THESE
THESE LATEST TECHNOLOGIES. AND
SO THE GREENVILLE EXAMPLES, YOU
GIVE. YES, THERE ARE SO MANY
LESSONS TO BE LEARNED BY BY
HOMES HERE IN CALIFORNIA, BUT
ALSO FROM, FROM RESEARCH THAT
WE'RE DOING NATIONALLY. AND FOR
MY COLLEAGUES, BECAUSE I
MENTIONED IT TO YOU IN OUR
MEETING WHEN THE CCU FIRE
HAPPENED, IT WAS STILL BURNING
OVER IN BONNY DOON. AND THE
SHERIFF TOOK ME UP THROUGH BIG
BASIN. AND HE SAYS, I WANT TO
SHOW YOU SOMETHING. AND WE GO UP
THIS ROAD WHERE IT HAS BEEN
COMPLETELY BURNT, AND WE GET TO
THE TOP AND THERE IS A HOME THAT
IS UNTOUCHED. AND THEY DID STUFF
AROUND IT. IT HAD THE DIFFERENT
KIND OF IMPERVIOUS SURFACES AND
THAT FIRESTORM WENT RIGHT
THROUGH THERE. AND THAT HOME
SURVIVED. AND SO AND I DON'T
THINK THAT WAS THROUGH YOUR
PROGRAM OR PROGRAM. THEY JUST
DID IT. SO I AM WONDERING HOW
YOU JUST MAKE SURE THAT YOU
INCORPORATE THAT. YEAH SO
OBVIOUSLY THE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THEY TALKED
ABOUT IS REALLY AIMED AT THOSE
ARE THAT ARE LOW INCOME. BUT HOW
DO WE EDUCATE ALL CALIFORNIANS
IN WILDFIRE PRONE AREAS THAT
EDUCATION AND THOSE RESOURCES
ARE ALSO CRITICAL IN FRONT FOR
US, MAKING SURE THAT THAT EVERY
HOMEOWNER HAS ACCESS TO THIS
INFORMATION, WORKING WITH OUR
BUILDING INDUSTRY, MAKING SURE
THAT CONTRACTORS ARE
KNOWLEDGEABLE OF WHAT STEPS THEY
CAN TAKE, MAKING SURE THAT OUR
LOCAL FIRE OFFICIALS AND
BUILDING OFFICIALS ALSO KNOW
THESE STEPS SO THAT THEY CAN
INCORPORATE THEM INTO LOCAL
ORDINANCES. IT'S DOING ALL OF
THESE THINGS ALL TOGETHER THAT
WILL REALLY MAKE US A MORE
HARDENED STATE, A MORE RESILIENT
STATE. AN OBSERVATION ON WHAT
YOU SAID, BECAUSE IN THAT
PARTICULAR FIRE, IN PORTIONS OF
THE SANTA CRUZ MOUNTAINS, THOSE
PEOPLE THAT BOUGHT IT A LONG
TIME AGO, IT WAS NOT AN UPGRADED
HOUSE. THEY WEREN'T MAKING A LOT
OF MONEY. IT WAS A STRUGGLE FOR
THEM. IF THEY WERE TO RETROFIT
THEMSELVES. AND IT'S A STRUGGLE
FOR MANY OF THEM TO EVEN
REBUILD. AND SO IT TARGETING
THOSE THAT DON'T HAVE ECONOMIC
RESOURCES IS PROBABLY I'VE, I
PICKED UP CLEARLY THAT YOU SAID
YOU TARGET THE REST FOR
INFORMATION BUT IT IT JUST
MAKING SURE YOU TARGET IT. THEN
THE OTHER QUESTION I WANTED TO
ASK THAT SORT OF RELATED IS
THERE WERE AND I LOST TRACK TIME
RUNS TOGETHER. 2 OR 3 YEARS AGO
THERE WERE FIRE MAPS RELEASED,
ALL OVER, AND THEY WERE RELEASED
FOR COMMENTS. AND THEY WERE OF A
LOT OF THE RURAL AREAS. AND
THERE WAS A BIG PUSHBACK FROM
PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT OVER THE
FACT THAT THE FIRE MAPS DID NOT
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT MITIGATIONS
THAT HAD BEEN DONE. AND SO THERE
WAS THIS WORRY THAT INSURANCE
COMPANIES WOULD TAKE THESE MAPS
AND MAKE DECISIONS WHEN THERE
HAD BEEN MITIGATIONS OR
CONTROLLED BURNS OR OPEN THINGS
OR RETROFITTING, AND THEREFORE
THEY FELT THAT. HOW WERE YOU
AROUND WHEN THAT HAPPENED? HOW
WAS THAT RESOLVED? AS, AS TO THE
EXTENT IT WAS, HOW WAS IT
ADDRESSED AS AN ISSUE WHEN THAT
HAPPENED? YEAH, I WAS AROUND. WE
HAD BEEN WORKING ON THAT PROJECT
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS. FIRST TO
BUILD, THE, THE SCIENCE MODEL
THAT WE USE, A SCIENCE BACKED,
FIELD TESTED MODEL. TO YOUR
POINT, THOUGH, A MODEL THAT
INCORPORATES HAZARD FACTORS.
THESE ARE FUEL TYPE, TERRAIN,
FIRE HISTORY, FIRE WEATHER, NOT
NECESSARILY MITIGATIONS LIKE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND HOME
HARDENING. PRESCRIBED FIRE.
THOSE MITIGATIONS ARE CRITICAL.
SO DON'T DON'T GET ME WRONG, BUT
HAZARD MAPPING IS LOOKING AT
LONGER TERM FACTORS THAT DON'T
CHANGE OVER TIME. DEFENSIBLE
SPACE HAS TO BE DONE CONSTANTLY,
ANNUALLY. YOUR POINT ABOUT THE
EARLIER HOME THAT A HOME THAT
WAS HARDENED 20 YEARS AGO MAY
NOT HAVE THE SAME HARDENING
EFFECTS OR MATERIALS THAT WE
CONSIDER TODAY, AND SO WE DON'T
INCORPORATE THOSE THOSE RISK
ELEMENTS OR FACTORS INTO OUR
HAZARD MAPPING. BUT I ALSO IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THESE FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY ZONE
MAPS THAT WE ARE CHARGED WITH,
WITH CREATING REALLY ARE NOT
INTENDED IN ANY WAY TO BE USED
FOR INSURANCE PURPOSES. AND IN
FACT, WE USE WE WORK VERY HARD
AND COLLABORATE VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT IS
UNDERSTOOD BY INSURANCE
COMPANIES WHAT THESE MAPS ARE
AND WHAT THEY AREN'T. REALLY.
THE MAPS ARE INTENDED FOR LOCAL
LAND USE PLANNING DECISIONS, HOW
AND WHERE YOU BUILD HOMES, AND
GIVING THAT DATA IN THE HANDS OF
OUR LOCAL FIRE AND BUILDING
OFFICIALS TO HELP MAKE THOSE
DETERMINATIONS SO THAT THEY CAN
BUILD HOMES AND BUILD
COMMUNITIES TO THE RIGHT
STANDARD TO WITHSTAND FIRES. SO
KIND OF SEPARATING THIS RISK
VERSUS HAZARD HAS BEEN A BIG
CHALLENGE, NOT PER SE. ON ON
YOUR QUESTION, BUT OBVIOUSLY THE
INSURANCE SPACE IS WEAVED INTO
THIS, THIS CHALLENGE. JUST A
COMMENT TO CLOSE IT IN. I THINK
THAT IS THAT, I'M SURE THAT A
LOT OF MY CONSTITUENTS ARE STILL
VERY SKEPTICAL THAT THE
INSURANCE COMPANIES AREN'T DOING
THAT. AND IT MAY WELL BE TRUE
THAT THEY'RE NOT. BUT THERE IS I
THINK OVER TIME, WE HAVE TO WORK
ON THAT SKEPTICISM, BECAUSE THAT
IS A GENUINE CONCERN. LAST
QUESTION. AND WE TALKED ABOUT
IT. THERE HAD BEEN TIME RAIMES
WHEN THE PERMIT BACKLOG WITHIN
THE FIRE MARSHAL'S OFFICE HAD
BEEN EXTENSIVE, AND WHERE ARE
YOU NOW? IN WHERE THERE ARE ANY
BACKLOGS OR OR YOU KNOW,
PROBLEMS? YEAH. WE HAVE WORKED
VERY HARD IN OUR FIRE AND LIFE
SAFETY DIVISION THAT DOES ALL
THE PLAN REVIEWS FOR STATE
CONSTRUCTION, INCLUDING THE
BUILDING THAT WE ARE HERE IN
TODAY. AND WE HAVE WORKED TO
BRING THAT THAT BACKLOG DOWN AND
MAKE IT TO A NORMAL PROCESS. WE
HAVE RECLASSIFIED POSITIONS AS
ADDING SPECIALISTS THAT WERE
THAT ARE ENGINEERS, ARCHITECTS,
SO THAT WE COULD HELP ADD THE
DEPTH OF EXPERIENCE, BUT ALSO
FILL SOME OF THOSE VACANCIES
THAT WE WERE STRUGGLED WITH FOR,
FOR MANY DECADES. IN FACT, I'M
REALLY PROUD TO BE ABLE TO TELL
YOU THAT AS AN OFFICE, WE HAVE A
VACANCY RATE OF JUST ABOUT 15.
AND THAT WAS AS OF THE BEGINNING
OF THE MONTH. MANY OF THOSE
POSITIONS HAVE HAVE ALREADY BEEN
FILLED. AND SO TO THE BACKLOG
SPECIFICALLY, THAT HAS REALLY
BEEN WORKED OUT. WE'VE BROUGHT
IN NEW TECHNOLOGIES AND EMBRACED
THE ABILITY TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR OUR STATE PARTNERS AT DGS,
AT CORRECTIONS, AT THE
UNIVERSITIES, TO BRING THEIR
PLANS TO US, FOR US TO EASILY,
QUICKLY REVIEW THEM, MAKE SURE
THEY'RE COMPLIANT WITH THE FIRE
CODE, BUT THEN GET THEM STAMPED
AND APPROVED SO THAT
CONSTRUCTION CAN BEGIN. AND SO
THAT BACKLOG IS NOW A NORMAL
LEVEL OF BUSINESS FOR OUR FIRE
AND LIFE SAFETY DIVISION. IF IT
EVER STARTS TO ACCUMULATE. I'D
LIKE TO HEAR IT FROM YOU BEFORE
I HEAR IT FROM PEOPLE THAT ARE
IN LINE IN THE BACK. UNDERSTOOD?
SO WOULD I. OKAY. THANK YOU. I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE INDULGENCE
TO ASK THE QUESTIONS AND THE
RESPONSE. THANKS, SENATOR. I
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING IT.
THANK YOU, MR. SENATOR MADAM
VICE CHAIR, THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. A PROBLEM WITH
THE MICROPHONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, CHIEF, FOR MEETING WITH ME.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEND SOME TIME
WITH YOU. I KNOW THAT YOU HAD
ALREADY DISCUSSED SOME OF THE
FIRE SEVERITY MAPS AND HOW
THEY'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO AFFECT
INSURANCE, BUT THEY DO, AND THEY
HAVE BEEN. AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
MY CONSTITUENTS THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT YESTERDAY THAT ARE REALLY
STRUGGLING TO BE ABLE TO FIND
INSURANCE, TO ACHIEVE THE, YOU
KNOW, ONE OF THE AMERICAN DREAMS
IS TO HAVE YOUR OWN HOME, AND
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AREAS, YOU
HAVE TO ACTUALLY BE SO MANY
MILES WITHIN A FIRE STATION
REACH IN ORDER TO EVEN QUALIFY
FOR INSURANCE. NOW THERE'S
SEVERAL CANCELLATIONS COMING
THROUGH. ARE YOU WORKING WITH
THE, RICARDO LARA, THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER, TO TRY TO WORK
THROUGH SOME OF THESE THINGS AND
THE INTENTION OF WHAT THE FIRE
MAPS ARE? AND HOW'S THAT GOING?
YEAH, ABSOLUTELY. OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS, I'VE WORKED
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER HIMSELF, BUT ALSO
HIS DEPUTIES TO REALLY TRY TO
WEAVE IN WILDFIRE MITIGATION
INTO THE STANDARDS THAT THEY'RE
SETTING. I'M VERY PROUD TO SAY
THAT THE SAFER FROM WILDFIRES
PACKAGE THE REGULATORY PACKAGE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
PUT TOGETHER LAST YEAR INCLUDED
OUR INPUT AND OUR INVOLVEMENT
AND OUR VOICE, IF YOU WILL, TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE MITIGATION
FACTORS, MANY OF WHICH SENATOR
LAIRD MENTIONED DEFENSIBLE
SPACE, HOME HARDENING,
PRESCRIBED FIRE, FUEL REDUCTION,
ALL THESE EFFORTS THAT THEY'RE
TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION, WHEN
INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE LOOKING
AT SETTING THEIR AVAILABILITY
AND THEIR PRICING. NOW, YOU
KNOW, AS THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL,
I DON'T NECESSARILY REGULATE
WHAT THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY, BUT
IT HAS ABSOLUTELY BEEN MY
POSITION AND OUR POSITION AS A
DEPARTMENT TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE AND OUR
OTHER PARTNERS, INCLUDING THE
INSURANCE ASSOCIATIONS, TO,
AGAIN, MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
ALIGNED IN OUR MITIGATION
MEASURES SO THAT THOSE EFFORTS
CAN TAKE INTO ACCOUNT. I'LL TELL
YOU, I WAS ON A MEETING JUST
YESTERDAY WITH WITH THE DEPUTY
COMMISSIONERS TALKING THROUGH,
EFFORTS THAT THEY HAVE UNDERWAY
TO ENSURE THAT THESE WILDFIRE
MITIGATION MEASURES, BUT ALSO
THE HAZARDS THAT EXIST AND THE
EXPERIENCES OUR FIREFIGHTERS ARE
SEEING EVERY DAY ARE INTEGRATED
INTO THE WORK THAT THEY ARE
DOING AT THE END OF THE DAY,
MAKING SURE THAT CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
INSURANCE. THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE THAT. I'VE BEEN IN
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE
COMMISSIONER AS WELL. AND IT IS
I REALLY DO BELIEVE IT IS HIS
INTENT TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY HAS ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE INSURANCE THAT WILL
BE ABLE TO PROTECT THEIR HOME
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
MORTGAGE IS PROTECTED BECAUSE
THEY'RE REQUIRED TO HAVE THAT. I
APPRECIATE THAT, AND I
APPRECIATE YOU, ECHOING THOSE
COMMENTS, BECAUSE I THINK YOU
GUYS WORKING TOGETHER WILL MAKE
A BIG DIFFERENCE IN WHAT WHERE
WE HAVE TO GO WITH THIS
INSURANCE PIECE, I DO HAVE TWO
MORE QUESTIONS, MR. CHAIR, I DO
HAVE. WELL, PROBABLY THREE,
THERE'S A PIECE OF LEGISLATION
MOVING THROUGH THE BUILDING FROM
THE ASSEMBLY SIDE THAT JUST CAME
TO OVER US TO KIND OF REMAP AND
REVISE, FIRE SEVERITY HAZARD
ZONES, I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE
HAD A CHANCE TO LOOK AT THAT
LEGISLATION. I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
CAN COMMENT ON THAT LEGISLATION.
IF YOU CAN'T. I TRULY
UNDERSTAND. AND, BUT IF YOU CAN,
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT?
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU AND I'M NOT
ATTACKING OR SUPPORTING. I'M NOT
DOING THAT. I'M JUST SAYING
OFTENTIMES I FOUND THAT WE MAKE
DECISIONS THAT REALLY, WE THINK
SOUND GOOD AT THE VERY
BEGINNING. BUT ONCE IT GETS
IMPLEMENTED ON THE GROUND WHERE
YOU'RE AT, IT DOESN'T. AND THE
PEOPLE THAT YOU HAVE
IMPLEMENTING THIS STUFF, IT
DOESN'T IT DOESN'T WORK OUT
QUITE LIKE WE THOUGHT IT WOULD.
SO I'M INTERESTED IN THAT
PERSPECTIVE AND YOUR THOUGHTS IF
YOU CAN COMMENT ON IT. YEAH, WE
ARE STILL ANALYZING THAT BILL.
AND ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW, SEVERAL
DOZEN OTHERS THAT THAT THAT ARE
GOING THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE
RIGHT NOW RELATED TO WILDFIRE
MITIGATION. SO, YEAH, I CAN'T
COMMENT SPECIFICALLY ON ON THAT
BILL. BUT WHAT I WILL TELL YOU
IS IF THE IF THE LEGISLATURE
SETS UP A POLICY AND MAKES SOME
CHANGES TO HOW WE MAP AREAS OR
WHAT MITIGATIONS ARE REQUIRED,
WE WILL WORK HARD TO NOT ONLY
IMPLEMENT THAT, BUT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THERE ARE SCIENCE
BACKING INTO THE WAY THAT WE DO
IT, THAT WE PROVIDING EDUCATION
TO CALIFORNIANS SO THAT THEY CAN
BE SUCCESSFUL AT AT IMPLEMENTING
THOSE REQUIREMENTS. AND SO I,
YOU KNOW, I HAVE TO GIVE YOU I
KNOW YOU ASKED SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT A BILL THAT'S GOING
THROUGH RIGHT NOW, BUT I HAVE TO
NOTE THAT THERE HAVE BEEN A
NUMBER OF POLICY CHANGES THAT
YOU ALL HAVE SAID OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS THAT HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCES IN
HELPING US REALLY, INFORM, BUT
ALSO, ARM CALIFORNIANS WITH THE
STEPS TO, TO MAKE THEMSELVES
MORE RESILIENT. ONE OF THOSE
BILLS ACTUALLY CREATED AN ENTIRE
DIVISION WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT,
FOCUSING SOLELY ON FIRE
PREVENTION. SO ALL OF THESE
MITIGATIONS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT, DEFENSIBLE SPACE, HOME
HARDENING, WE HAVE A TEAM JUST
FOCUSED ON ON DOING THAT WORK.
AND SO AGAIN, I'LL LEAVE IT TO
ALL OF YOU TO MAKE THE DECISION
AS THAT LEGISLATION MOVES
THROUGH. BUT BUT NOTE THAT
WHATEVER CHOICE YOU MAKE, WE
WILL STAND READY TO IMPLEMENT.
AND AGAIN, AT THE END OF THE
DAY, WORK TOWARDS TRULY BUYING
DOWN THE RISK THAT THAT EXISTS
IN CALIFORNIA TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE STOP THE AMOUNT OF
DESTRUCTION THAT HAS OCCURRED
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. SO I KNOW
THAT WAS A LONG WAYS OF NOT
SAYING, THE POSITION, BUT BUT
BUT WE WILL DEFINITELY, LIKE I
SAID, CONTINUE TO MAKE,
MEASURABLE STRIDES TO MITIGATION
THROUGH YOUR LEGISLATION. THANK
YOU, ONE OF THE GREATEST BILLS I
WAS ABLE TO WORK ON WAS WITH THE
SENATE PRO TEM. PREVIOUS WHEN HE
WAS A FLOOR LEADER, WAS MAKING
SURE THAT WE FUNDED ENGINES AND
FUNDED, CAL FIRE. IT WAS JUST A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH,
THE ALL OF OUR FIRE DEPARTMENTS.
HE WE ARE FROM DIFFERENT PARTIES
. WE HAVE DIFFERENT OPINIONS
ABOUT THINGS, BUT WE BOTH
REPRESENT RURAL AREAS, AND WE
DEPEND ON YOU TO PROTECT NOT
ONLY OUR RANCH LANDS AND OUR
WIDE OPEN SPACES, BUT, YOU KNOW,
THE COMMUNITIES THAT YOU KNOW
THAT THE AREA THAT SURROUNDS
THOSE COMMUNITIES, ONE OF THE
REASONS I BELIEVE THAT WE BOTH
WORKED ON THAT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IS NOT ONLY TO MAKE
SURE IT WAS ADEQUATELY STAFFED,
BUT I SHARED THESE CONCERNS WITH
YOU ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH RIGHT.
WHO WORKS, YOU KNOW, 20 DAYS ON
AND IN THAT TYPE OF CAPACITY
WHERE YOU COME ACROSS CHARRED
BODIES, DESTRUCTION OF PROPERTY,
THOSE THINGS THAT CAN AFFECT THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT FIGHT THESE
FIRES, HAVE YOU, I KNOW YOU'VE
IMPLEMENTED SOME STUFF. WE
TALKED ABOUT IT YESTERDAY, BUT
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THE REDUCTION
IN HOURS AND THINGS TO ADDRESS
THE MENTAL HEALTH THAT, YOU
KNOW, I THINK THOSE THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE ACTUALLY ON
THE GROUND ARE SUFFERING WITH
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WHERE
THEY'VE BEEN REQUIRED TO WORK IN
THE PAST. BUT WITH THE FUNDING,
IT'S BEEN SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
HELPFUL TO YOU. YEAH. YOU KNOW,
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW, THE MENTAL
WELL-BEING OF OUR FIREFIGHTERS
IS PARAMOUNT. AND IN, IN THE
BUDGET THAT YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF
YOU IS OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW, A
SIGNIFICANT REQUEST TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE STAFFING COMPONENTS
OF ALLOWING OUR FIREFIGHTERS THE
TIME THAT THEY NEED TO GET OFF
AS THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL,
SETTING THE STANDARDS FOR
FIREFIGHTER TRAINING. THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS, I HAVE WORKED
HARD AND OUR TEAM HAS WORKED
HARD TO INCORPORATE PEER BASED,
SUICIDE AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TYPE OF TRAININGS, NOT ONLY
STANDALONE TRAININGS TO AGAIN
GET BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TYPE OF
CURRICULUMS OUT TO OUR
FIREFIGHTERS, BUT ALSO TO WEAVE
IT INTO ALL OF THE OTHER
FIREFIGHTER AND ACADEMIES SO
THAT AS NEW FIREFIGHTERS, YOUR
SON INCLUDED, GO THROUGH THE
BASIC ACADEMIES. THEY'RE THEY'RE
GETTING THE BEGINNINGS OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF MENTAL HEALTH, OF,
THE CANCER AWARENESS AND OTHER
THINGS THAT THAT DO IMPACT OUR
FIREFIGHTERS EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND SO, AGAIN, AS A STATE FIRE
MARSHAL, SETTING THOSE THOSE
TRAINING STANDARDS, THAT'S GOING
TO BE A BIG STEP. BUT OBVIOUSLY,
THE STAFFING COMPONENTS THAT YOU
ALLUDED TO IN THE WORK THAT YOU
ALL HAVE DONE, AND AGAIN, WHAT
IS IN THE BUDGET THAT YOU ALL
HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU, THOSE
THOSE WILL BE VERY MEANINGFUL IN
THE YEARS TO COME TO REALLY MAKE
SURE THAT OUR FIREFIGHTERS GET
THE TIME THAT THEY NEED TO BE
ABLE TO BE WITH THEIR FAMILIES.
BUT ALSO WHEN YOUR TIME AS THE
FIRES HAVE BEEN OCCURRING THE
LAST SEVERAL DAYS ALL AROUND
YOUR DISTRICT, WHEN YOUR TIME OF
NEED OCCURS THAT THOSE
FIREFIGHTERS ARE STILL AVAILABLE
AND THAT THEY ARE READY TO GO
AND MENTALLY PREPARED TO RESPOND
TO ALL EMERGENCIES. THANK YOU
SIR. AND MY LAST QUESTION IS, IS
THAT, YOU KNOW, I SHARED WITH
YOU AN EXPERIENCE WHERE MY I WAS
ACTUALLY ON A DAIS LIKE THIS,
AND MY HUSBAND SENT ME A TEXT
AND SAID, I'M GOING TO THE
RANCH. THERE'S A FIRE AT THE
RANCH, AND WITHIN 45 MINUTES HE
TEXTED ME BACK AND SAID, THE
RANCH IS ON FIRE. AND THAT'S A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT TEXT, A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT TEXT, I
LEFT HERE AND I WENT DOWN THERE,
AND WHEN I GOT THERE, WE SPENT,
YOU KNOW, TRYING TO PROTECT
STRUCTURES AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
Tê, I SHARED WITH YOU THAT I
LOVE THE FACT THAT THEY'RE NOT
JUST PEOPLE OUT THERE FIGHTING
FIRES. AND WE CAN BE A JERK IF
YOU WANT TO, BUT THEY'RE REALLY
WHAT I WOULD CALL RETAIL
FIREFIGHTERS. LIKE, THEY MEET
THE NEED OF THE PERSON THAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO HELP, WHO'S IN
A PRETTY STRESSFUL SITUATION
WITH LOSING THEIR PROPERTY AND
STUFF. AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I TALKED TO YOU ABOUT THAT
I HAVE GRAVE CONCERN OVER WHICH
YOU ADDRESSED, AND I'D LIKE YOU
TO ADDRESS THAT AGAIN TODAY, IF
YOU WOULD. IS THAT THE
FIREFIGHTERS CAME, DID THEIR
JOB, DROPPED THE STUFF, THE
HELICOPTERS, THE WHOLE THE WHOLE
BIT. AND THEN AT NIGHT, THERE
WERE THESE CREWS THAT CAME AND
THEY WERE LOADED DOWN WITH ALL
THIS EQUIPMENT AND ALL THIS
STUFF, AND THEY STAYED AT NIGHT
TO GO BACK AND GO HIT THE HOT
SPOTS, AND THEY WERE SECOND
CHANCERS, THEY WERE INDIVIDUALS
WHO'D BEEN INCARCERATED OR
INCARCERATED, PERSONNEL THAT
WERE WORKING TOWARDS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR WHEN THEY GOT
OUT. THE BEST WAY FOR KEEP THEM
FROM GOING BACK IN IS A JOB,
RIGHT? AND BEING ABLE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THE OUTSIDE WORLD.
AND, BUT THAT PROGRAM HAS BEEN
ELIMINATED. BUT YOU REASSURED ME
THAT YOU'RE STILL EMPLOYING
INDIVIDUALS LIKE THAT, BUT
THROUGH OTHER AVENUES. CAN YOU
ADDRESS THAT, PLEASE? YEAH. LET
ME NOTE THAT THE PROGRAM, THE
JOINT PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
REHABILITATION STILL EXISTS,
WHILE WE HAVE SEEN REDUCTIONS IN
THE NUMBER OF AVAILABLE INMATES
DUE TO A WHOLE HOST OF DIFFERENT
ISSUES, OUR FIREFIGHTING HAND
CREW PROGRAM HAS REALLY
TRANSITIONED. AND WHILE WE STILL
HAVE, AGAIN, A PROGRAM WITH CDCR
AND OUR INMATES, WE HAVE
EXPANDED WITH FUNDING FROM THE
LEGISLATURE AND FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION, AUGMENTING OUR
RESOURCES, HAND CREW RESOURCES
WITH OUR OWN FIREFIGHTERS, WITH
C.C.C. CORPS MEMBERS, AND WITH
THE CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD OR
THE MILITARY DEPARTMENT. AND SO
REALLY NOW WE HAVE A VERY
DIVERSE GROUP OF FOUR DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS, ALL PROVIDING HAND
CREWS. BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, NOT
ONLY DO WE HAVE HAND CREWS TO
FIGHT FIRES, WE HAVE THESE HAND
CREWS FROM THESE FOUR DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS TO DO FIRE PREVENTION
WORK, FUEL BREAKS, PRESCRIBED
FIRE, IN ADDITION, WE HAVE FOUND
THAT ESPECIALLY THE C.C.C.
PROGRAM AND THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD PROGRAM HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN AN ENTRYWAY INTO
CAREERS IN FIREFIGHTING, THE
C.C.C. THOUGH THEY MAY SAY IT A
LITTLE DIFFERENTLY, WE ARE SUPER
PROUD THAT AT OVER 500 CORPS
MEMBERS FROM THIS PROGRAM HAVE
GONE ON TO CAREERS WITH US,
ALMOST 100 WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD. AND THAT'S GIVEN
US JUST THIS ENORMOUS, DIVERSE
CANDIDATE POOL FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO FILL THE CRITICALLY NEEDED
FIREFIGHTING POSITIONS. BUT
AGAIN, TO GIVE A PATHWAY FOR
CORPS MEMBERS THAT GO THROUGH
THIS SEC, BUT ALSO TO STILL MAKE
SURE TO YOUR POINT, THAT EVEN
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE
FORMERLY INCARCERATED HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO BE FIREFIGHTERS
THROUGH THROUGH ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT ITERATIONS. I
APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE BEING AN
EMPLOYER IN THE STATE FOR 30
YEARS, IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
SOMETIMES FIND PEOPLE THAT ARE
SECOND CHANCERS A JOB. WE USED
TO PLACE 55% OF THOSE SECOND
CHANCERS THAT CAME FROM ALL OVER
THE STATE IN THE OIL INDUSTRY,
AND THAT'S DWINDLED DOWN TO
ALMOST NOTHING BECAUSE OF
POLICIES. BUT I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'RE STILL MAKING SURE THAT
THEY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE
EMPLOYED. THANK YOU, SIR, FOR
ANSWERING MY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU, SENATOR. THANK YOU, MADAM
VICE CHAIR. MR. BERLANT, I THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE. JUST
A COUPLE OF ITEMS. AND FIRST AND
FOREMOST, GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
WORK. YOU ARE WAY DEEP IN THE
WEEDS, NO PUN INTENDED, AND KNOW
YOUR STUFF, AND CHIEF TYLER AND
THE TEAM IS LUCKY TO HAVE YOU. I
THINK THERE'S A FEW AREAS OF
FRUSTRATION. DO YOU WANT TO
SHARE? AND THIS ISN'T YOUR DOING
WHATSOEVER. YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU
LOOK AT, LIKE, FOR EXAMPLE,
KELSEYVILLE RIVIERA, WHICH WAS
GRATEFUL TO BE ABLE TO VISIT
WITH, SOME OF THE LAKE NAPA
COUNTY UNIT, EVEN WITH 45 TO
$60,000 WORTH OF HOME HARDENING,
FOLKS ARE STILL NOT GOING BE
ABLE TO GET INSURANCE. AND WHERE
THE FRUSTRATION IS, IS THAT
MOODY'S HAS COME OUT WITH A
REPORT. YOU HARDEN YOUR HOME 40%
LESS LIKELY TO BURN, HARDEN YOUR
HOME, DO VEGE MANAGEMENT ON YOUR
PROPERTY, 75% LESS LIKELY TO
BURN. AND I THINK WHERE THE
FRUSTRATION WITH CONSUMERS AND
AGAIN THIS IS NOT YOUR DOING
SIR. AND YOU ARE DOING AN
AMAZING JOB. SO PLEASE DON'T
TAKE THIS AS THROWING STONES. IS
THAT DESPITE THE INVESTMENTS
THAT WE'RE MAKING, WHETHER IT'S
45 $50,000 PER HOME IN STATE
SUBSIDY OR THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT WE'VE INVESTED IN
DÂN DIÆN TREE REMOVAL VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT, BUILDING FIRE
BREAKS, INSURANCE IS NOT TAKING
THOSE INTO ACCOUNT TO BE ABLE TO
START WRITING IN IN THE
TRADITIONAL MARKET. AND I THINK
THAT'S THE CRISIS THAT WE HAVE.
ARE THESE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE MAKING,
YET HOMEOWNERS ARE STILL UNABLE
TO RECOUP THAT TRADITIONAL,
MARKET POLICY. I THINK THAT'S
THE DISCONNECT WHERE I THINK
THERE'S FRUSTRATION, ON THAT AND
WHICH WE ARE TRULY APPRECIATIVE
OF YOUR CONTINUED WORK, BUT I
THINK THAT'S AN ITEM THAT WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO TAKE UP,
ESPECIALLY IF WE LOOK AT A
COMMUNITY WIDE HARDENING PLAN
AND A COMMUNITY IS DOING WHAT'S
RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO REDUCE RISK.
AND INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE IN
THE BUSINESS OF REDUCING RISK,
THEN THERE WE'RE GOING HAYWIRE.
SO I THINK IN YOU'RE ABLE TO
FEEL FREE TO COMMENT IF YOU'D
LIKE. BUT THOSE ARE MY COMMENTS.
AND I THINK SOME OF THE
DISCONNECT THAT WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW IN THE STATE, BUT I
APPRECIATE WE SAY BECAUSE IT'S A
SHARED FRUSTRATION, PERSONALLY
AS WELL, IN MY OWN ABILITY TO
ACCESS INSURANCE IN A HOME
THAT'S IN A FIREWISE COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE A FIRE SAFE COUNCIL. I
HAVE DEFENSIBLE SPACE. AND SO,
YOU KNOW, TO JUST, YOU KNOW,
PIGGYBACK ON ON AN EARLIER
COMMENT THAT IS WHY I'M WORKING
REALLY HARD WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL THOSE MITIGATION MEASURES
YOU JUST MENTIONED, THAT I KNOW
AND OUR FIREFIGHTERS KNOW MATTER
THAT THE INSURANCE REGULATIONS
INCORPORATE THOSE THOSE
MITIGATIONS ALIGNING OURSELVES
AT THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY LEVEL
WITH RESEARCHERS, WITH US AT CAL
FIRE IS GOING TO BE REQUIRED FOR
THIS SOLUTION. I THINK WE ARE ON
THE RIGHT TRACK, THOUGH
OBVIOUSLY PEOPLE ARE FEELING IT
TODAY AND WANT RESULTS TOMORROW
ON THEIR, BEING ABLE TO ACCESS
INSURANCE. BUT I'LL JUST TELL
YOU THAT AS, AS THE, THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL, I'LL CONTINUE TO
BE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE TO BEING
THE VOICE OF WILDFIRE
MITIGATION, TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE MITIGATIONS THAT MATTER
ARE INCORPORATED BECAUSE, AGAIN,
I'LL TELL YOU, IT IS SOMEWHAT OF
AN INCENTIVE FOR HOMEOWNERS TO
DO THE WORK THAT WE'RE ASKING
THEM TO DO IF THEY CAN GET
INSURANCE. BUT IF WE GO AND ASK
THEM, CREATE DEFENSIBLE SPACE,
INVEST THIS MONEY INTO HOME
HARDENING, AND THEN THEY LOSE
THEIR INSURANCE. THE UNFORTUNATE
PART IS THEY DON'T SEE THAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR IT BECAUSE WHEN
THE WILDFIRE OCCURS NEXT YEAR OR
TEN YEARS LATER, WE'RE GIVING
THEM AN INCREASED CHANCE OF THAT
HOME SURVIVING. BUT THE
SHORTENED PORTION OF IT IS THEIR
ABILITY TO GET INSURANCE, AND SO
IT'S A VERY COMPLICATED PROBLEM.
BUT AGAIN, WE JUST HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO STAY FOCUSED ON
ALIGNING OURSELVES ON THE
MITIGATIONS THAT MATTER AND
MAKING SURE THOSE ARE COUNTED.
YEAH. AND THAT'S WHERE I THINK
IT'S GOING TO HAVE TO TAKE LOOK,
I'LL BE THE FIRST TO SAY THE
INDUSTRY DOES NOT LIKE MANDATES.
AND THE REASON WHY WE DON'T SEE
AGAIN, I'M GETTING A LITTLE
ASTRAY HERE, SO I'LL BRING IT
BACK. BUT THE REASON WHY WE
DON'T SEE HOME HARDENING OR
COMMUNITY WIDE HARDENING OR THE
BILLIONS THAT WE SPEND AS A
STATE, STATE DOLLARS IN WILDFIRE
MITIGATION IS BECAUSE IT WOULD
BE A MANDATE IN THE INDUSTRY,
AND THE INDUSTRY FIGHTS,
MANDATES AND THAT'S THE BOTTOM
LINE. FEEL FREE TO FACT CHECK ME
ON THAT, SO, BUT WE'RE AT THIS
POINT WHERE WE'VE INVESTED SO
MUCH IN PUBLIC DOLLARS AND THE
PUBLIC ISN'T SEEING THAT RETURN
IN THE INVESTMENT, WHETHER
THEY'RE NEIGHBORS AND TAXPAYERS
HAVE MADE OR THEY'RE MAKING
PERSONALLY. AND I THINK THAT'S
THE BIGGEST PIECE WHERE WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO CHANGE, BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S WHERE CAL FIRE
NEEDS TO GO. AND I ALSO KNOW
THAT, CHIEF TYLER WAS
PARTICIPATING IN A TOWN HALL,
TALKING ABOUT ALL THE GOOD WORK.
AND I THINK HE PROBABLY GOT, FOR
EVERY ONE QUESTION ON WILDFIRE
MITIGATION, PROBABLY TEN
QUESTIONS ON INSURANCE. SO IT'S
AN ISSUE THAT WE DESPERATELY
NEED TO BE ABLE TO RESOLVE. IT
IS AND I THINK WE ALSO NEED TO
CONTROL EXPECTATIONS. IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE OVERNIGHT. BUT WE
ALSO ALL HAVE TO COMPROMISE. AND
I THINK THAT'S WHERE, I WILL
SHARE WITH MY FRUSTRATION THE
ONE BIT OF GOOD NEWS. IF THEY DO
GET THOSE GRANTS, THEY'LL NO
LONGER BE TAXED, SINCE WE'RE
PUTTING THAT INTO THE BUDGET, ON
THAT. SO THAT'S GOOD NEWS ON ON
STATE WILDFIRE MITIGATION
FUNDING. CAN YOU JUST TALK TO US
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT, AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND THE 90% THAT YOU
JUST SAID THAT'S WITHIN THE WUI,
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT, IN
REGARDS TO HOW WE CAN QUICKLY
HELP THOSE HOMEOWNERS WHO MAY BE
ON FIXED INCOMES OR THEIR, JUST
NOT ABLE TO ACHIEVE WHAT THE
FINANCIAL OBLIGATION IS. CAN YOU
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT?
WELL, I THINK WE'RE ON THE RIGHT
TRACK. RIGHT? WE KNOW WHAT
MEASURES NEED TO BE DONE TO
HARDEN A HOME, YOU KNOW, WE KNOW
KHÓ. AND I THINK OUR ARE BETTER
SOCIALIZING THE IMPORTANCE FOR
HOMEOWNERS OF WHAT HOME
HARDENING REALLY IS. THE OTHER
PIECE, TOO, IS THAT WE'RE WE'RE
REALLY PARTNERED SIDE BY SIDE
WITH THE BUILDING INDUSTRY, WITH
DEVELOPERS WHO, AGAIN, ARE
WORKING FOR NEW HOMES. BUT
AGAIN, BACK TO THAT 90. THOSE
EXISTING HOMES, THIS FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM, WHILE RIGHT
NOW, YOU KNOW, WE'VE DONE A
COUPLE HOMES, IT WILL QUICKLY
SCALE UP AND THE STATE, YOU KNOW
UNFORTUNATELY WE SEE DISASTERS.
AND SO WE HAVE ACCESS TO
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS, SOME
YEARS, BILLIONS OF HAZARD
MITIGATION DOLLARS THROUGH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND SO IF WE
CAN AGAIN, REFINE THIS PROGRAM
AND THEN TAP INTO THOSE FEDERAL
DOLLARS, THAT WILL BE A HUGE
AMOUNT OF AVAILABLE PUBLIC FUNDS
TO HELP US, BUT THERE'S GOT TO
BE SOME OTHER PIECES THAT WE'RE
NOT CURRENTLY LOOKING AT WAYS TO
INCENTIVIZE. AND I WON'T GO TOO
MUCH INTO DETAIL BECAUSE THERE
ARE THERE, YOU KNOW, THERE IS
PENDING LEGISLATION AND THERE
HAVE BEEN LEGISLATION,
LEGISLATIVE BILLS IN THE PAST AS
WELL. BUT WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO NOT JUST EDUCATE, INFORM
AND SUPPORT OUR VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS, BUT HOW DO WE
INCENTIVIZE IT FOR EVERYBODY? I
DON'T KNOW ALL THE ANSWERS FROM
A POLICY PERSPECTIVE OF HOW TO
DO THAT. ALL I CAN DO IS MAKE
SURE THAT WHEN, WHEN, WHEN THAT
POLICY IS SET BY BY ALL OF YOU,
THAT WE STAND READY WITH THE
TOOLS AND THE FRAMEWORK FOR
LOCAL FIRE OFFICIALS AND
BUILDING OFFICIALS AND
HOMEOWNERS TO KNOW AGAIN, WHICH,
WHICH MEASURES MATTER, WHICH
SHOULD BE PRIORITIZED AND HOW
CAN THEY TRULY HARDEN THEIR
HOMES SO THAT WHEN A FIRE DOES
OCCUR, THEY HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
CHANCE OF THAT HOME SURVIVING?
THANK YOU SO MUCH, STEVE. LET'S
SEE IF THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE HEARING. AND SEEING
NONE. WE'RE GOING TO OPEN IT UP,
CHIEF, TO BE ABLE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. SO IF FOLKS
CAN PLEASE COME FORWARD, IF YOU
CAN, PLEASE GIVE US YOUR FIRST
AND LAST NAME ALONG WITH YOUR
ORGANIZATION, YOU HAVE 30S.
PLEASE STEP FORWARD TO THE
MICROPHONE. WE WELCOME YOU.
THANKS FOR HANGING WITH US AND
FOR YOUR PATIENCE TODAY. GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS TODD GOLDEN. I'M THE
BUSINESS MANAGER FOR SPRINKLER
FITTERS LOCAL 709IN LOS ANGELES,
SPRINKLER FITTERS LOCAL 709
WOULD LIKE TO STAND IN SUPPORT
OF CHIEF BERLANT. WE FEEL HE'S
THE RIGHT PERSON AT THE RIGHT
TIME FOR THIS JOB, SO GOOD LUCK,
CHIEF. THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
MAKING THE TREK UP. ALL RIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON. NICE TO SEE YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD TO SEE YOU,
TOO. STACY HEATON WITH THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA, REPRESENTING 40
RURAL COUNTIES STATEWIDE AND
CHAIR MCGUIRE, WHEN YOU SAID
THAT CHIEF BERLANT WAS THE MOST
PATIENT PERSON IN THE ROOM, I
THINK YOU'RE PROBABLY RIGHT
ABOUT THAT. AND A LOT OF
RESPECTS, OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
CHIEF BERLANT STARTED ABOUT TEN
YEARS AGO WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
TREE MORTALITY TASK FORCE. AND
HE HAS BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
OUR COUNTIES EVER SINCE HE'S
GONE OUT INTO OUR COUNTIES TO
HELP EDUCATE THEM ON HOW TO
TEACH THEIR RESIDENTS ABOUT HOME
HARDENING AND DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
HE HAS CHAMPIONED PROGRAMS SUCH
AS THE HOME HARDENING PROGRAM
THAT WE'VE ALREADY HEARD SO MUCH
ABOUT, AND IS WORKING OUT IN OUR
COUNTIES TO GET THAT UP AND
RUNNING, HE AND I HAVE BECOME
PERSONAL FRIENDS. I'M NOT AFRAID
TO SAY THAT. AND I DON'T THINK
THERE COULD BE A BETTER PERSON
WHO CARES MORE ABOUT THE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND WELFARE OF THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA FOR THIS JOB, AND
WE'RE PROUD TO OFFER OUR SUPPORT
FOR HIS CONFIRMATION TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD TO SEE
YOU. THANK YOU. HEY. GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON.
MELANIE PERRIN, ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATE GENERAL CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA, WE ARE HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF CHIEF BERLANT.
ON A PERSONAL NOTE, I USED TO
WORK WITH HIM IN THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR OVER TEN
YEARS, AND I CAN SPEAK TO HIS
LEADERSHIP, HIS COMPASSION, HIS
INTEREST. YOU TALK ABOUT THE
KNOWLEDGE IN THE WEEDS CHAIR, IT
IS PHENOMENAL. AND BEYOND
ANYTHING I COULD EVEN COMPREHEND
. SO, SO GRATEFUL FOR YOUR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH YOU IN
THAT SPACE AND ALSO NOW AS BEING
A PART OF THIS ORGANIZATION, THE
RESPECT THAT YOU'VE ALREADY
GARNERED FROM OUR CONTRACTORS,
YOUR COLLABORATION, YOUR
PROACTIVE NATURE, AND YOUR
SOLUTION ORIENTED, HOW YOU ARE
LOOKING TO SOLVE COMPLEX
PROBLEMS IN FINDING SOLUTIONS
WITH US AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE CAN SOLVE THIS ALL
TOGETHER. SO WITH THAT, WE OFFER
OUR STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANKS, MILLIE. GOOD AFTERNOON
SIR. NICE TO SEE YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS, MY NAME IS
RANDY ROBERTSON. I'M WITH THE
SPRINKLER FITTERS ASSOCIATION,
CALIFORNIA, COMPRISED OF
SPRINKLER FITTERS, LOCAL 43 709
AND 669, WE APPRECIATE THE
LEADERSHIP OF CHIEF BERLANT AND
SUPPORT HIS CONFIRMATION. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU. HEY. WELCOME BACK. HELLO.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS.
MEGAN SUBERS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS, WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS STRONG SUPPORT ON BEHALF
OF MY 35,000 MEMBERS FOR STATE
FIRE MARSHAL BERLANT, A LOT HAS
BEEN SAID TO HEAR SAID HERE
TODAY ABOUT HIS DEDICATION TO
THE FIRE SERVICE. SO I WILL JUST
TOUCH ON ONE THING THAT HASN'T
BEEN MENTIONED. THE STATE OFFICE
OF THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL IS
THE, EMPLOYER SPONSOR OF THE
JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM. THE
STATEWIDE PROGRAM THAT TRAINS
ALL THE FIREFIGHTERS IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT IS WHERE THOSE
TRAINING, THINGS ARE CARRIED OUT
ON BEHALF OF, YOU KNOW, NEW
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TRAINING
STANDARDS AND EVERYTHING ELSE
THAT COMES WITH BEING A
FIREFIGHTER IN CALIFORNIA. WE'VE
APPRECIATED WORKING WITH HIM
THROUGHOUT HIS YEARS OF SERVICE
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA, AND
WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEGAN. GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR, AND
HONORABLE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
TANYA HOOVER, THE DEPUTY UNITED
STATES FIRE ADMINISTRATOR AND A
RETIRED CALIFORNIA STATE FIRE
MARSHAL. I'M PRIVILEGED TO HAVE
WORKED WITH CHIEF BERLANT DURING
MY HONOR TO SERVE AS THE
ASSISTANT STATE FIRE MARSHAL AND
AS A CONFIRMED STATE FIRE
MARSHAL. AND I HAVE TO SAY, IT'S
NICER TO BE ON THIS SIDE. DURING
THIS TIME. HE SHOWED HIS
ABILITIES TO BRING PEOPLE
TOGETHER AND WALK THEM THROUGH
DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS AS HE
SERVED AS A KEY PERSON IN CAL
FIRE'S COMMUNICATION. AS THE
DEPUTY UNITED STATES FIRE
ADMINISTRATOR, I CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH CHIEF BERLANT AS HE
STRIVES TO BRING CALIFORNIA'S
FIRE SERVICE NEEDS AND
PREVENTION MESSAGES TO THE
NATIONAL STAGE BY SHARING THE
UNIQUE CHALLENGES OF A LARGE
STATE AND A VERY DIVERSIFIED
POPULATION AND LANDSCAPE. THIS
INCLUDES HIS UNDERSTANDING AND
SHARING OF DATA THAT WILL HELP
TO ADDRESS THE INCREASED
NATIONAL FIRE THREATS THAT
INCLUDE NATIONAL WILDFIRE
THREATS. THE SHARING STRENGTHENS
THE NATION'S ABILITY TO TACKLE
THE INCREASED FIRE LOSSES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. HE CONTINUES HIS
LEADERSHIP IN BRINGING PEOPLE
AND GROUPS TOGETHER TO
STRENGTHEN FIRE AND LIFE SAFETY
ISSUES THAT AFFECT THOSE THAT
VISIT, WORK AND LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THROUGHOUT OUR
NATION. I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE COLLABORATIVE
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHIEF BERLANT
AS HE MOVES THROUGH THE
CONFIRMATION PROCESS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE FIRE MARSHAL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE. HI. GOOD
AFTERNOON. HEY. HI. DANG GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. MY NAME IS
REBECCA LIGHT, AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA FIRE PREVENTION
OFFICERS. WE OFFER OUR
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT FOR CHIEF
BERLANT TO THE POSITION OF STATE
FIRE MARSHAL. HE HAS BEEN AN
OUTSTANDING CONTRIBUTOR AND
COLLABORATOR IN THE FIELD OF
FIRE PREVENTION. AND WE'VE HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF WITNESSING
FIRSTHAND HIS REMARKABLE
ACTIVITY AND DEDICATION TO FIRE
AND LIFE SAFETY IN ALL
COMMUNITIES AND ITS CITIZENS
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT HIS CONFIRMATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE. GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR. MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
TIMOTHY SPEARS. I'M HERE
SUPPORTING THE NORTHERN
GOVERNOR. I'M HERE REPRESENTING
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FIRE
PREVENTION OFFICERS AND
EXPRESSING OUR SUPPORT FOR
CONFIRMATION OF DANIEL BERLANT
AS THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL. WITH
SEVERAL YEARS OF DEDICATED
SERVICE AS CAL FIRE CHIEF.
BERLANT HAS DEMONSTRATED
EXCEPTIONAL LEADERSHIP AND
EXPERTISE. HIS WORK AS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY WILDFIRE
PREPAREDNESS AND MITIGATION, AND
HIS TENURE AS ACTING STATE FIRE
MARSHAL, HAS BEEN MARKED BY
IMPROVING WILDFIRE PREVENTION
AND COMMUNITY SAFETY. CHIEF
BERLANTS COMMITMENT TO
PROTECTING LIVES AND PROPERTY
MAKES HIM AN OUTSTANDING
CANDIDATE, AND WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT HIS CONFIRMATION TO THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE. HI. GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'M JOE
MORELLI. I REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE PREVENTION
OFFICERS, SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
DIVISION. I'M HERE TO EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT FOR CHIEF BERLANT
AND SERVING AS STATE FIRE
MARSHAL. CALIFORNIA NEEDS A
LEADER IN THIS IN THE STATE IN A
IN A FIRE MARSHAL WHO WILL LEAD
ALL OF US IN PROTECTING OUR
COMMUNITIES. CHIEF BERLANT HAS
DONE EXCEPTIONALLY WELL AS STATE
FIRE MARSHAL, LEADING US IN
WILDFIRE MITIGATION, STATE FIRE
TRAINING, CODE DEVELOPMENT AND
OTHER COMMUNITY RISK REDUCTION
PROGRAMS. CHIEF BERLANT PRESENTS
HIS FIRE SERVICE LEADERSHIP AND
SUPPORT OF THE FIRE SERVICE AND
OUR COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. IT'S BEEN PALPABLE AND
WE'RE HERE TO EXPRESS OUR
COMPLETE SUPPORT FOR CHIEF
BERLANT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANKS FOR MAKING THE TREK UP.
HEY. GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CATHERINE FREEMAN, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
58 COUNTIES, WE'VE HAD AN
INCREDIBLE TIME WORKING WITH
CHIEF BERLANT AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUED WORK WITH HIM. WE
ENCOURAGE YOUR APPROVAL OF HIS
NOMINATION, I'LL JUST SAY HE'S
ENTERTAINED SOME VERY DIFFICULT
DISCUSSIONS AND HAS MAINTAINED
HUMOR, AND INTEGRITY BOTH
TOGETHER AND, IN DIFFICULT
CONVERSATIONS. AND WITH
COUNTIES, IT CAN BE DIFFICULT TO
TALK ABOUT FIRE PREVENTION,
FIREFIGHTING, THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS. SO WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO
APPROVE HIS NOMINATION AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
GOOD TO SEE YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIRMAN.
MADAM VICE CHAIR DAN DONMOYER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. WE
REPRESENT THE HOME BUILDERS OF
THE STATE. WE ARE HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE CONFIRMATION OF
CHIEF BERLANT. I JUST WANT TO
ECHO HIS COMMENTS. AS BUILDERS,
WE HAVE PERSONALLY WALKED
PROPERTY WITH HIM ACROSS THE
STATE TO FIND WAYS TO BUILD OUR
HOMES IN A MORE RESILIENT AND
FIRE SAFE MANNER. HE'S
PERSONALLY WORKED WITH US TO
DEVELOP THE TOUGHEST FIRE
STANDARD CODES OF ANY BUILDING
INDUSTRY IN AMERICA. ALTHOUGH
HE'S TOUGH, HE'S FAIR. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT COLLABORATION,
SO WE STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT HIS CONFIRMATION. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANKS FOR YOUR PATIENCE. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MY NAME IS RUBEN
GRIJALVA. I'M SPEAKING FOR
MYSELF. I SERVED AS THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL AND DIRECTOR OF CAL
FIRE IN THE SCHWARZENEGGER
ADMINISTRATION. AND WHILE I WAS
DIRECTOR, CHIEF BERLANT WAS
HIRED AS A YOUNG, PUBLIC PUBLIC
INFORMATION OFFICER IN OUR
COMMUNICATIONS DIVISION. EVEN
BACK THEN, YOU COULD RECOGNIZE
HIS TALENT AND HIS LEADERSHIP.
I'VE WATCHED HIM IN HIS CAREER
AS HE'S RISEN TO THE RANKS OF
THE FIRE MARSHAL'S OFFICE. AND I
WILL SAY TO YOU, HAVING BEEN IN
THOSE SHOES AND DEALT WITH THE
COMPLEX ISSUES AND, YOU KNOW,
THE VARIOUS ISSUES THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL'S OFFICE HAS TO
DEAL WITH. AND IN MY 35 YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN THE FIRE SERVICE,
I WILL TELL YOU TODAY HE IS THE
RIGHT MAN FOR THE JOB. AND HE'S
GOING TO BE AN OUTSTANDING
LEADER AND A GOOD TEAM MEMBER
FOR CHIEF TYLER, THANK YOU SO
MUCH, CHIEF. APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE, BRINGING IT HOME
WITH MR. REED. I DON'T KNOW WHAT
I DID. I HAVE TO HAD TO FOLLOW
THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR. AND NOW
RUBEN RUBEN, I'LL TELL YOU, IS A
GREAT, GREAT FRIEND. A LONG TIME
FRIEND, HELPED US RECONFIGURE
THE NAME CAL FIRE, AND HE'S HE'S
GREAT. HISTORIC GUY IN CAL FIRE
HISTORY. I GO BACK 45 YEARS WITH
CAL FIRE AND I'VE SEEN AND KNOWN
ALMOST ALL OF THE FIRE MARSHALS,
ALL THE DIRECTORS, ALL THE
CHIEFS, BUT THIS MAN WE JUST HAD
LUNCH LAST WEEK, WE STAY IN
TOUCH. WE'RE IMPRESSED WITH WHAT
HE DOES. EVEN THOUGH I DO MORE
OF THE WORK FOR THE CAL FIRE
LOCAL TWO EIGHT, EIGHT ONE AND
MORE WITH CHIEF TYLER. BUT I'M
GREAT, GREATLY IMPRESSED WITH
YOUR DESIRE TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND WORK WITH LOCAL
281. AND WE APPRECIATE THIS
COMMITTEE'S CONCERN. YOU BROUGHT
UP THE MENTAL HEALTH OF
FIREFIGHTERS, AND THAT'S. THANK
YOU FOR THAT, IT'S A BIG ISSUE.
THEY DO WORK A MONTH AT A TIME.
GET ONE DAY OFF, GO BACK FOR
ANOTHER MONTH. AND IT STRESSES
THE FAMILY ENORMOUSLY. AND I'M
SO HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY TO
HEAR ALL OF YOU RECOGNIZE THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR. REED.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. WE'RE
GOING TO DO A LAST CALL FOR
THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. THIS IS GOING TO BE OUR
LAST CALL. WE'RE GOING TO NOW
LOOK TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
ADVANCE, PLEASE DO SO AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT. HEARING SEEING
NO ONE, WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
YEAH. PLEASE, MADAM VICE CHAIR,
I HAVE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
I'D JUST LIKE TO MOVE THIS
HONORABLE, EXCEPTIONAL LEADER TO
THE FLOOR FOR A FULL VOTE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MADAM VICE CHAIR. MADAM
SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL? MAGUIRE AYE. MAGUIRE.
AYE. GROVE. GROVE. AYE. EGGMAN
EGGMAN. AYE. JONES. JONES. AYE.
LAIRD. LAIRD AYE. 5 TO 0 FIVE
ZERO. CONGRATULATIONS, CHAIR.
JUST ONE. JUST ONE COMMENT. I
KNOW WE TOOK THE VOTE, BUT I'VE
BEEN ON THIS COMMITTEE FOR
SEVERAL YEARS AND I THINK YOU
JUST BEAT MARK GHILARDUCCI ON
SUPPORT. I REALLY DO THINK YOU
DID. I THINK THAT, MORE PEOPLE
GOT UP AND SPOKE. AND IN BEHALF
OF YOUR LEADERSHIP AND YOUR
EXCEPTIONAL WAY THAT YOU HANDLE
PROBLEMATIC SITUATIONS AND LOOK
OUTSIDE THE BOX, THEN MARK GOT
LAST TIME. SO I'M HUMBLED. I'LL
LET HIM KNOW THAT. IT MAKES HIM
FEEL REALLY GOOD ABOUT THAT. SO
I LIKE THAT. THANK YOU, CHIEF.
CONGRATS. NEXT UP IS THE SENATE
FLOOR. WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE
HERE. AND I'M SURE JACKSON IS SO
INCREDIBLY PROUD OF YOU TODAY.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
32ND RECESS. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
A 32ND RECESS. YEP. AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO COME BACK AND
WE'RE GOING TO ADD ON FOR OUR
ONE ITEM ON CALL. AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO GO INTO EXECUTIVE
SESSION. SO WE'RE GOING TO COME
BACK AND DO OUR ADD ON HERE IN
ABOUT 30S. CHIEF THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT BACK. WE
HAVE ONE ITEM ON CALL. THAT'S
ITEM ONE. SEE, MR. PAULSON,
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS GROVE?
GROVE? AYE. 5 TO 0. THAT'S A50
VOTE. THAT ITEM PASSES. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN, THIS CONCLUDES
TODAY'S PUBLIC PORTION OF THE
AGENDA. WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT
EACH OF YOU TOOK THE TIME TO BE
ABLE TO ATTEND THE SENATE
COMMITTEE RULES WILL NOW MOVE TO
EXECUTIVE SESSION. WE'RE GOING
TO ALLOW FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO
CLEAR THE ROOM. WE'RE GOING TO
BE STARTING EXECUTIVE SESSION
SHORTLY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.